e
good afternoon everyone we're going to
call this work session in division three
to order today is Friday February 21st
2025 our purpose today has been
published in the calendar so it's been
duly noted publicly we are division
three of house finance we have a 1M work
session today it's a budget work session
services for the record I'm state
representative Moren money of the town
of
miramac our chairman representative Jess
Edwards could not be here
today just a few budgeting notes in
general I just want to point out that
what we do here in house finance
divisions is recommended to the full
Finance so though we may take action or
give uh motions and so forth ours are
just recommendations to the full finance
committee as we go through the budget
process we are obliged to have a
balanced budget that is we cannot spend
more than we take in and that can be
located in RSA 99 colon 8 hyphen
lowercase
b compatible with that is house rule 48
which says that we work in close
collaboration with the house Ways and
Means Committee in order to know just
how much it is we can
spend for today's presentations uh we'll
make it very clear what page number
we're working off of what accounting
unit we're working off of you'll notice
already in our packets I think we're
going to cover probably close to
10 and what
sections also want to make mention of
the incredible resources that are found
for this division all the divisions
house finance and the entire budget
process both on the department of
administrative services
website and through the general court
website the LBA legislative budget
assistant everything that we work off of
documents large large and small what you
may think is relevant what you may think
is not relevant can be found on those
two pages incredible resources for
everything that we look at here in
division three as well as the other
divisions as we go forward today I'd
like to uh have the presenters uh talk
about prioritized needs naturally as
best you can uh with this sort of notice
so that is related to what DHHS wanted
and what the governor perhaps funded in
her proposals also vacancy rates if we
could uh discuss that as we go along
presentation
wise I'll be taking no motions today but
I do encourage the members to take notes
clear notes in terms of uh things that
may catch your eye of what may be
discussed or amended or proposed later
sessions deadline just want to remind
everybody for division 3 we're looking
at a March 27th
correct me if I'm wrong but a March 27th
Target in terms of getting out our
amendments to house bills one and two so
I've I've since learned that March 27th
may be a possible session day so the
other division the other analysts are
telling their divisions March 26 so I
would assume that for the time being
okay March 26th that's a little
better I think that's it for my
introductory comments anything from the
members of division three representative
tarki thank you than you so much
chairwoman
Mooney um when we finished our last
meeting on
Wednesday I was I had some questions
about some Medicaid policy changes that
the governor had alluded to um and we
talked about my concerns about going
into this informational session this
afternoon um without any information on
policy changes um since then I've had a
number of conver ations and I've gone
digging a little bit but what happened
after that session closed well actually
uh while the meeting was still going
chairman Edwards said oh I have a
document it's really easy it's the five
bullet point document which I had not
seen a number of people had not
seen I received the document now it's
unclear to me who wrote this document
it's not an official letterhead um I
don't know what it is or where it came
from um but I believe a number of us now
have this document and I guess I just
want to express my concerns because I
dug into the RSA 9.9 colon
2-a which revolves around transmission
to the legislature of the budget and um
this is the section that states that not
later than February 15th I'll jump ahead
a little bit the governor shall transmit
to the legislature a document to be
known as the trailer Bill containing any
changes to statutory law deemed
necessary for the ensuing bium we know
it is House Bill
2 um it was recently um amended to then
state that the electronic file needed to
be posted on the Das website on the date
of transmitt and we have a copy of that
um it's draft format and there's nothing
in this document that actually has
policy changes to Medicaid
that are reflected in the five bullet
point document in
question so number one I'm a little
concerned about the lack of
transparency of upcoming policy changes
um that should have been transmitted to
the legislature by February 15th that
aren't there we also got an email saying
from one of our members in full Finance
saying we don't expect to see House Bill
2 or the trailer bill until March 1st so
again that's another I think that puts
us as over a week from today so I am
really
uncomfortable that we are going to be
discussing signif significant policy
changes that are going to affect tens of
thousands of granite Staters and their
health care coverage without official
documentation on the changes that are
coming so I guess I'll start there
as a starting point for this session and
I want to thank the people who have um
answered my questions and concerns up to
this point but you did just state that
all the documents we're working on can
be found on the website and I don't
believe that the document in question is
on the website is that correct well I
would um we can start there thank you
for your comments that was a lot so I
want to get to all of that we'll start
with yes the document of the five point
points I have the same copy as you
including the
notations this will be discussed today I
believe it originated with Mr Lipman
correct me if I'm wrong and I was in
discussions this morning quite early
with Mr Ripple and I insisted that this
very document be on the website seeing
as though we will be looking at it today
so Mr Ripple and I discussed that at
length do you have a timeline Mr Ripple
as to when the document in question and
uh I don't know really what to call it
but it's Five Points as representative
tarki described related to Medicaid
discussion points has that been posted
if not when it hasn't so I'm about to
put that as well as today's presentation
materials online so they'll be up within
the next five minutes within the next 5
minutes as for um House Bill two
now I've not been here
forever however it seems like a a
reoccurring issue that it doesn't come
out at simultaneous with the governor's
budget presentation despite the RSA you
quoted with a specified
date so in terms of how to um go forward
with that I think it's comparative to
other years previous years and um my
thought is we just have to wait that out
now a correspondence did come through
today I don't know who it was from that
OSS will be working on the finalized
version next week so it sounds like
things are moving but as for completion
I don't have an answer Mr Ripple do you
have anything to add to that uh we've
heard from OS that they plan to have the
draft uh the the the bill ready for
introduction by the end of next week and
is it your understanding like mine that
this has happened in previous cycles
that house bill 2 is
delayed yes there usually is a delay
because they go through the document
that the governor's office provided and
they make sure that all the references
are correct Etc and they put it into a
format that's consistent with other
bills and because it's so long it
typically does take a while so I think
this turnaround time is pretty
typical representative T sure thank you
I just want to comment on that because
we were able to receive this draft
that is I have in my house bill two
binder right here we got this draft that
was posted last Friday evening and the
fact that this information was available
in a different format that this could
not be included somehow in that draft I
I just I find that extremely difficult
uh to comprehend like it I'm really
concerned about transparency here and I
know there's nothing we can do and I
know I've heard this is the way we've
done it for years um I know that this
section of rsay was amended July 1 of
2023 where I think we attempted again to
clarify what was required but I am just
I apologize for taking so much time I
expressing my frustration with this
process and the fact that we are not
prepared to have a deep dive into these
extreme policy changes that are proposed
so I won't take any more time and I
thank you for letting me Express
that okay I would uh just add to that
just just a quick comment representative
for for clarification purposes I I don't
think I have a copy I don't think I have
a copy of that five point but having
said that the question is is we're
talking about federal policy changes
that no we're talking about State policy
changes y okay there's a document that
maybe was drafted and is what the
governor wants to do it's unclear it is
literally just type on a piece of white
paper okay
um are
you are you all set representative yeah
I think so okay uh well I just want
again clarify um my response to the
house bill two issue is not this is the
way it's always been uh it's just my
response is this is how it is so I just
want to make that distinction very clear
um the document in question so the Five
Points which will be up on the website
within the hour which we will get to um
I I consider a working document it has
potential for amendments to House Bill
two uh which we will spend spend plenty
of time on as a division uh but that is
for all intensive purposes a working
document that we will look at today
whether or not it's going to be in the
final version or you know the version
that's going to be published that I
can't answer to I can just only manage
uh today's work
session okay anything further from
division three members all right with
that we're about to tread now on correct
me if I'm wrong but this is the the
largest uh accounting units in the
entire state budget process and that is
Medicaid services just to point out and
highlight uh the enormity of our task
and um and all that you do which reminds
me I want to thank all of you uh for all
of the work you put into this uh we all
get caught up in details and figuring
things out and the whole nine yards is
out cers but but you uh have done so
much work to prepare and to familiarize
yourself and come back with answers and
so forth we are deeply grateful for the
time you put into the preparation and
presentation so with that I'll hand it
over to the both of you on our work
session Medicaid services excellent uh
good afternoon uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services and I'm here
today joined by I'm Henry Litman the
state's Medicaid director so
just just to kick things off uh and
address a little of the conversation
that's transpired here this morning um
we've we have before you uh a couple of
uh different documents um the first is
the PowerPoint presentation and we will
be going through the policy changes that
are described in the document that was
being discussed before we've included
some Financial details on the specific
impacts as well as some of the federal
regulations regarding those policy
changes so that will be discussed in
detail today I just I just want to make
that clear I I would probably recommend
using this as as the the document of of
record and and maybe set aside that that
other uh PowerPoint or that other bullet
document for the time being um in the
governor's operating budget we will
begin on page
885 and we will be discussing the
accounting unit
that run through Page
893 again that's the governor's
operating budget 885 through 893 so
while it is a large um budget area of
the department and the state there's
actually relatively a smaller number of
accounting units um because of the
nature of the funding and how it's
accounted for and then finally in the uh
DHHS budget briefing book um the the
Medicaid begins on page one of that
document and just as a quick reminder
the only accounting units that are
included in the budget briefing book are
the account accounting units that are
over $1
million and so with that brief update
and orientation I'm going to hand it
over to Henry to start to go through the
Medicaid
Program thank you um if you turn to uh
slide
two so what we intend to cover uh this
afternoon with you and certainly we'll
take questions as you would like to um
we try to anticipate what you might like
to to learn about and but we're
certainly open to hearing um to compare
the agency and the governor uh budget uh
just as a high level in this budget the
difference between the agency budget and
um the governor's budget is about $60
million in reductions um that are in the
budget as you know uh or may not know uh
the granted Advantage Healthcare program
is an off-budget item and there are $10
million of reductions in that um and
then we'll
um uh try to speak a little bit to some
of the issues that are um being
discussed at a federal level that would
impact this budget uh greatly
potentially and then we have an appendix
um some of which uh if you attended our
medic 101 there's some that material
there but we added some other materials
that we think you might be interested in
if the time allows um and certainly if
you need more time with us we'll make
ourselves
available um I'm now um going to um
slide four oh Mr Litman we appear to all
have a question already okay so that
would be representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman again
um just as a clarification so we're
talking about a $70
million difference between the agency
budget and the governor's budget over
you representative Daniels for a
question thank you I I I thought you
uh Advantage was off budget I stand
correct you $70 million reduction in the
budget okay 60 of which is within what
we're looking at in terms of and just as
a followup is there a reason why that's
off budget as opposed to the included
when we're trying to look at the whole
so the Department's agnostic about where
it is it was a legislative decision okay
thank
you representative Stringham for a
question yeah um uh is the comparison
based on the efficiency budget or a
budget with prioritized needs and uh
just quick follow up to that as
well sure well I I I guess the question
is how how would you like it compared
because
um not to be difficult but so in the in
the operating budget chapter 106 for the
current bium um we have the budget but
then there were dollars included uh in
the Medicaid rates that were included in
hb2 so we we can compare it you know
just from the the governor's budget here
in front of us but if you'd like us to
look at it a different way we we can
certainly do
that um just I I guess the the question
I I was just trying to uh determine what
framework you were using um and uh I
there's probably value in looking at it
many different ways so
um sure so I I I I would just need to
confirm uh representative pri's um
number there I just take one minute to
to validate that go ahead continue so um
slide four page four um the division of
Medicaid
services provides what I think you would
all understand to be like the health
insurance program that people have
Medicaid um there are other parts of the
department um where my division helps
with the financing of other areas like
for example in long-term services and
supports which is a budget you hear
later this pictogram on the right hand
side here is just to to sort of say that
Medicaid has a division but we're also
play a financing role in terms of we're
as the Medicaid agency we're the sort of
the direct uh connection to the federal
government for Medicaid and um they look
to our division with respect to the
compliance of the program and and what
have you um also on this page on the
bottom right paragraph I would note that
um in New Hampshire about one in seven
individuals are enrolled in the Medicaid
Program that compares nationally to one
in
five Slide
Five um New Hampshire um sorry see
yeah Madam chair I have a a quick
question sure representative novano for
a question yeah um thank you Mr
lman um so the one in seven is based on
expanded the expanded Medicaid coverage
or the the entirety of the Medicaid
Program that enrollment against the
state
population okay and the one in five is
against the US population nationally
okay thank
you representative tarki for a question
so a quick followup that's that 180,000
or 189,000 that we talk about yes thank
you um and just another s on moving to
slide five um we are the fourth smallest
Medicaid program in the country in terms
of as measured by
enrollment
um we you know in addition to the
medical um program we offer um dental
care which is you know hard to
disconnect from the medical the mouth is
part of the body and we um you know the
legislature approved an adult program um
in that started in April of 23 uh
children in for for dental are up to age
21 you're considered a child for
purposes of dental care and that's
through a FIFA Service as opposed to a
Managed Care model um as I mentioned um
the second bullet we're the interface
with the federal government um centers
for Medicaid Medicare services and we
work with all the divisions in one way
or the other in terms of um helping
where there is federal funds available
for support of services and where
Medicaid coverage can come in and I'll
Point some more of those out as we go
along um and you know basically
we're um leveraging um the general funds
and other funds that are available in
the state to deliver Services uh to uh
many individuals um and includes also
children in school who are um have IEP
and 504 plans um we mention at the
bottom there and I'll cover more of this
as we go through um some some
programming that uh has come through our
11:15 waiver um an adult community
re-entry what that is is for the first
time um federally the the prohibition
about um inmate in exclusion that
they're allowing um states to be able to
draw federal funds to help with the
transitions of people leaving um the
correction setting as you may or may not
know that in New Hampshire the number
one reason for people to have recidivism
back to uh presid in our jail is that
often times mental health and substance
use disorder uh being untreated and so
what this program tries to do is get
people connected to those Services
before they leave and to provide
medications so there's less of a risk
it's a very limited program but is
designed to um help with um Health Care
ultimately for the Medicaid Program but
will also be helpful to the correction
system in our state in terms of the
number of people that
um and then um briefly on page
six um talk about some of our key few
key accomplishments and um I won't
belabor this uh today but um um youth
re-entry is a federal requirement of all
states that began in January it's
somewhat similar to what I described as
the adult community re-entry it's a
little bit more tailored program
um in the correction system there are
people who um would be considered adults
in that system but um in Medicaid
they're still considered a child in fact
um former foster care um are entitled to
youth benefits until they're until they
turn 26 and so what this uh program
tries to do is make sure that those
services that um Define what a child's
needs are are identified before they
leave that there's transitions set in
place um so that when they come out um
hopefully if they're eligible for
Medicaid that that's already
established and that uh they have extra
provided um one of the questions that we
fielded was about the Medicaid unwind
during the continuous coverage which
went from March of 2020 to um March the
end of March of 23 States had the first
opportunity to um unwind from The
Continuous coverage um federal
government asked states to take at least
nine months and in many instances they
needed more um we were substantially
completed in 9 months for the most uh
vulnerable population Like Home and
Community Based and nursing homes we
took the longest to it's just relatively
smaller population but we were we were
accomplished pretty much from April 1st
to at the end of the calendar year um we
were largely complete um and we um had
to catch up on over 200 in this case
238,000 roughly redeterminations that
weren't done during the the um Public
Health Emergency because they people
didn't have to what I would give the
state credit for is we tried to work
with people because you may or may not
remember that at one point during the um
Federal Public Health Emergency it was
being renewed every 90 days and so we
didn't want uh people to lose coverage
because we didn't have the capacity to
respond to them so we tried to work some
of that down in advance with individuals
and so we got about 30,000
redeterminations done ahead of time
which gave us a little bit more
bandwidth to be responsive to the to our
citizens and to the people in the
program when we saw closures um sorry
representative tarki for a question um I
the fact that we're talking about the
unwind is why I just want to stop
briefly um the document the bullet
document section one um when I read it
which talks about return to regular
eligibility redetermination when I first
read it I sort of thought to myself well
we've already done this can you please
explain to me what section one on the
document means and what this will
um the during the the end of the public
health emergency and the beginning of
the unwind um there were Federal
authorities that states could use
because trying to catch up on
238,000 um
redeterminations you know wasn't just a
problem for New Hampshire was a problem
for the whole country um that um they
gave us different flexibilities like we
gave people a bit more time because they
may some people who came on the program
had never done a redetermination before
um for for older people time it takes
time to you know get documents and
things and um we were able to use
different authorities to to ease the
burden if you will of getting back into
the routine for some people it was four
years since they had to go through um a
redetermination and so those authorities
are available to us until June of this
year and so what um the statist IC
that's on slide four there is what we're
anticipating based on what we've seen
and despite I think efforts that far
exceed what many states did in terms of
trying to get people to complete their
work and um we went well above and
beyond what was required there's still
the PE there are a number of people who
still don't do that work and if they
don't do that work for redetermination
we're at some point we have to close
them and that is Factor ented into um
that number one on the the piece of
paper that uh chair money
um and and you had brought to our
attention so um that's I guess the what
we modeled as being the financial impact
of returning to regular pre-pandemic
redeterminations okay
so do you have an estimate of how many
people are going to be
affected with this continued
redetermination of
Eligibility um I I do have that number I
I yeah okay thanks um so um that's
deputy director um for Medicaid Program
David choury um so in terms of um one of
the things that we did during the
federal Public Health Emergency is um
look to increase the level of expart
renewals meaning um those that could be
renewed based on if we already have the
information through our sources we don't
ask the person to provide information
that we already have so the the part of
the flexibilities around what we could
use for information that's going to
scale back so we're we're anticipating
this to the EXP parte rate will come
down about 2,000 individuals a month and
we're expecting about half of those
individuals uh you know our experience
has been about
51% um won't won't uh stay
open now the thing to point out about
Medicaid is that it's unlike um private
insurance where there open enrollment
periods Medicaid's continuously open so
if someone does close and they do feel
that they need it they can reapply and
there's no waiting
period okay thank
you Mr White you wanted to add to that
sure U from a budgetary perspective in
state fiscal year 26 um we would
anticipate this change would be about
$5.7 million of General funds and
equivalent amount of
Federal and then in the budget it's also
at in say fiscal year 27 at
approximately 11.4 million doll of
General funds and the corresponding the
same amount of federal dollars for the
second
year okay okay sure okay representative
Stringham for a question and I think
that wraps up this I I round of
questions I think pretty pretty much
understand so you're saying you
basically have a of the 8,000 or so that
uh if you're looking at four over the
next four months of doing um or is it
2,000 a month going to continue into the
next bium you're still going to be
working people off and doing
redeterminations that your initial
budget did not include it's required to
be done annually um and so we're
expecting that there'll be a certain
amount of churn people some people come
back but then some people
won't isn't that business as usual for
the Medicaid Program yes and that's
that's why we call it return to regular
um representative priest for a question
thank you madam chairman again for
clarification um the 5.7 million that
you are estimating for 2026 is that cost
savings and 11 for 2027 yes so so that
reduction that you just referred to
that's reflected in the governor's
operating budget that that you were
looking at before you and again that's
because you
anticipate um a number of people will be
redetermined and will
be taken off of Medicaid actually it's
that they won't that after noticing and
the time allowed that they choose okay
or aren't able to do it okay thank you
um if I could add one more comment um
one of the things that came out of the
federal Public Health Emergency
experience for us and the continuous
enrollment is all during the federal
Public Health Emergency and the
continuous enrollment we actually
reached out to individuals to see if
they really wanted to stay on Medicaid
and surprisingly there's you know
sometimes if you don't ask that they
need it anymore they don't do anything
about it so we we found in the last 12
months there were 11,000
individuals who close based on Outreach
now we also reach out to people who
close to make sure that if they need
redetermined and we'll get into this a
little bit more later on but I'll just
throughout this statistic today because
I think we'll give you a little bit of
feel like in the the granted Advantage
Program the average tenure on the
program is less than a year um and there
are 87,000 people approximately in the
last year that were on the program you
know the today's enrollment is just
around
60,000 so there is a level of people
coming on having their needs met or uh
by either um leaving the program
Medicaid all entirety or that they may
be disabled or something and they're
going to a different level of
Medicaid and so I think that you know
we're try trying to be responsible to
make sure that people who are eligible
and want to get there that we're doing I
think extensive Outreach much more than
was ever done um and those people that
are letting us know that you know hey
I've got other insurance now I don't
really need it you can close me um in
fact you know just anecdotally there was
a period of time in the pandemic where
um
CMS um had had made a rule change and
the courts said you can't do it that way
and we had to reopen people had some
anecdotally a few complaints from people
saying I still didn't want Medicaid why
did you reopen me and so you know we we
do um I'm not saying that's the majority
in anyway but I'm just saying there's
there is an element of individuals who
their needs change and and they no
longer need it and there still is um
particularly with children We call we
still today call every family um we have
the MOs make calls and we make calls to
find out kind of where they're at um and
uh you know it isn't all about closing
people it's about making sure those that
are eligible if we can reach them that
and they need help in um completing it
that we support them representative
priest thank you madam chairman um out
of the people that apply for Granite
State
Advantage uh how many are rejected
because they just don't meet the crit
criteria um the this the criteria for
granted advantages uh is just an income
only criteria I don't have that stat
with me I don't know if my team does or
not uh but U um we could get that
statistic for you and that 11,000 that
you talked about about people closing
yes is that was that just a particular
month or was it no that's for entire
12month period for for 2024 uh would be
from actually the period that we measur
Meed that I'm speaking to is uh from
February 1st of last year to through
much um and the last bullet on that page
was you know we re reoccured the entire
um Medicaid Managed Care Program for
another uh five years um and um we
appreciate that the legislature uh
reauthorized for seven years which
helped I think us get a better contract
and um and we you know used our
experience over the number of years to
make refinements in the program and I
know today we're trying to focus on
budget so I'm going to maybe come back
to more of that later if there's time um
on slide seven just provided some
information that allows you to compare
in different eligibility groups how New
Hampshire compares to the United States
on
average and you know you can see the 1
in seven and one in5 five repeated again
at the top
there on slide eight um oh we do have a
question Mr Litman couple questions
representative Daniels followed by
representative walner thank you is there
a difference between being on Medicaid
and being in the uh a granted Advantage
Program they're both Medicaid programs
it's really the federal match that the
benefits are exactly the same um you
know an adult in Medicaid who's not on a
w gets the same benefit as someone on
granted Advantage okay I'm just trying
to reconcile uh your comment that there
were 50 thou about currently about
50,000 in the granted Advantage but yet
on page seven you're talking about
185,000 that's that's the entire
Medicaid population not just granted
Advantage okay thank
you representative
walner thank you when you did the rewind
and you started having people leave the
program do you have numbers as to how
many children went off how many people
in nursing homes went off how many
people yes on granted Advantage so those
would those be available to us in fact
um later on the presentation I think
we'll come across a table that has that
information thank
you proceed Mr Lipman thank you um I'm
on slide
eight and um I'm not going to spend time
on this but I thought for interest based
on the fact that your the House of
Representative represents typically
County boundaries largely but not it's
just so you can see in terms of the
standard Medicaid Program and granted
advantage and in total what the
enrollment is in your your communities
that you serve and let me make this
point too while I'm right here is that
um when we run numbers of about
enrollment there are different ways you
you might see the numbers vary a bit um
there's a we have open we do enrollment
all during the month so sometimes we're
reporting on the last day of the month
sometimes we're reporting on who was
covered during the month like when I
said you know granted Advantage you know
there are people who come off and on all
the time so some some data runs were
running um you know through the month
and some are just end of the month
points
question representative tarki for a
question thank you very much looking at
this map or looking at slide eight there
the middle map yes um I'm seeing that
6055 persons so I'm assuming this is the
ex Medicaid expansion granted Advantage
yes so this is another topic that I'm
sure we are going to talk a lot about
but with New Hampshire having a trigger
law that if there's any drop of federal
funds below 90% our program of granted
Advantage will expire so would I be
correct in seeing this that 7.2% of the
New Hampshire population would lose
their Medicade
coverage
um I think that that's what uh that
let me do a double check in my math on
7.2% yeah no it's not of this entire
population right it's um CU 180 one 87
in
yeah I'm not correct on that number so
let me have someone run the calculation
but it it is uh if 185 is approximately
one and one and seven right so it would
be onethird of the one and seven would
be the kind of math of that well as you
can imagine I'm extremely concerned
about the potential impact to Granite
Staters so I'm sure we will dig into
those numbers and your team can figure
out the impact of that thanks and I I
will have a comment that sort of
addresses that very shortly in the slide
deck
um again a couple facts here in terms of
um uh the top left hand side of uh slide
nine um you know New Hampshire 22% of
our births are under Medicaid nationally
that's
42% um
in terms of the bottom um left hand side
the chart we cover 15% of the women in
New Hampshire um who are in the 15 to 49
versus 21%
us um and the chart on the right just is
um I think with the granite Advantage
program and such you know our uninsured
rate it's not the lowest in the region
but is is is lower than many others
um and on slide 10 um I get to the point
I think that um you were trying to rate
a moment ago representative um that the
way New Hampshire is structured right
now in terms of its Insurance Market we
have of course the Medicaid
Program um
the the granted Advantage part in
particular um if that were to to close
if you kind of think about risk pools
you've got the um private insurance
through employers employer sponsored
insurance you have um the
ACA um coverage that's available to
people and then you have um the Medicaid
Program and and you may remember at one
point when we started granted Advantage
we began it in the um the ACA
Marketplace effectively by buy buying
private insurance and while our first uh
year or two of experience was not bad it
it actually saw it push up rates in the
in the individual market and so what my
point here on on the right hand side is
even if you don't have Medicaid you
should have an interest in the issue of
of coverage because while we've achieved
something as a state in terms of with I
think having granted advantage and the
1332 waiver in terms of bringing
our rates of coverage outside of
Medicaid down if this population is no
longer covered in the Medicaid Program
it probably will have I think a negative
effect on everybody who's buying
insurance on the individual Market or um
in on ACA coverage um and so I think
that there's a reason to care about
Medicaid even if you're not on Medicaid
because I think it has a positive effect
on the overall market and you can see
with a 1332 waiver and granted advantage
on the left-and side that New
Hampshire's premiums have come down and
and today while they're still very
expensive their our ACA coverage is
either the lowest or second lowest
consistently
now on the topic of waivers Mr Lipman is
there a way to find a list of waivers or
is that available yes um and I'm not
sure if we have in the slide deck our
waiver wheel but if not we have
a we can get that information readily to
you perfect representative Stringham for
a question so uh you you indicated that
um um eligibility and enrollment in
Medicaid has a positive effect on
reducing premiums for manage care and
Commercial plans and those types of
things that are often paid for by New
Hampshire uh employers did I understand
that correctly what I was saying is the
the granted advantage population is more
expensive in the commercial Market than
it would push up the rates based on
their use use rates if you will compared
to it not being there and if you may
recall the insurance department actually
did a study on what the impact was of
moving from where it was back into the
Medicaid Program that there were Savings
in the commercial market for that so so
um as a followup would you be concerned
that um a policy change on on the
Medicaid Program uh or or the granite
Advantage Program May reduce um
um the um the enrollment rate in the
Medicaid Program and then having kind of
the the reverse reverse Boomerang back
to to the manage care
plants I believe I believe that is a
possibility I can't say with certainty
because I'm not an economist but that
that's my assessment of what would
happen based on what happened initially
which is rates went up when we pulled
the granted Advantage population back
into the Medicare program and with the
1332 waiver of the insurance department
our rates got a lot better as a
state representative priest for a
question thank you madam chairman back
on
page eight um when you compare the
various programs in New Hampshire on the
standard Medicaid Program um what
127,000 um are children below the age of
18 below 18 I may not remember up the
top of my head but I think what we
Define as a child in Medicaid is just
around
990,000 um 90,000 of that 127 yeah it
may be 88 something but it's close to 9
,000 when you consider all the different
you
um slide um 11 if if we could is just
the um organizational chart for the
Medicaid Program um sort of key leaders
in their 10e um the division of Medicaid
is is maybe smaller than might expect
it's 33 individuals
um um support the the this this division
12 um if we looked at this two years ago
our our vacancy um which is the second
column of this chart um we had a vacancy
rate approaching I think about a third
um we've been fortunate to um be able to
bring that down again thanks in part to
the work the legislature did in terms of
making wages better but also I think
that we've done a lot of good things um
in terms of improving policies in
Medicaid um that make it a more
interesting place for people who want to
contribute to that activity as a place
to work so we're grateful for what has
been done
um and um so um in terms of our
vacancies uh today we have three um we
have um in the budget process we had
three uh positions that were unfunded
and two that were
um um I'm not sure what the right term
is eliminated that were um during the
the re
uh review of how people would be um
compensated some people went from um
classified position to unclassified the
the UN um the classified positions were
abolished um and they were clinical
people where that's where there were a
lot of wage pressures and um and so
that's kind of I think what's happened
there um I'm not sure if there anything
else you would add there to what I just
described
no so um now getting into um uh starting
on slide 14 we're gonna U sort of work
through the
um the budget briefing book is as um
Nathan had um relayed earlier um I think
um we've tried to in red put a couple of
uh key takeaways but as we go through
this I'm going to try to um give you
some Concepts about what's going on in a
particular area and then get into the
numbers so um in
1371 was the maternal opioid misuse
model model this was a um a centers for
Medicaid Medicare service demonstration
model um that uh runs through um
December of of this year uh it's been
was originally intended to be a
five-year model um it was allowed to go
on for six years because of the pandemic
um it was a a pilot project in the
greater Manchester area to um try to
help moms um and children when there was
opioids um involvement to um to have a
successful pregnancy and and successful
aspect with their children um we're not
asking for any funds in this one so this
this I think is a fairly straightforward
um
area representative walner for question
just a really simple question how many
um mothers and children were involved in
this program um it obviously there's
turnover I think today we're running
about 137 mothers in the program thank
you representative priest for a
question yes and how many mothers are
there now that are out there that are
needing a program like this and we have
no
program um well the program is
continuing to December we're we're
working on part of these demonstrations
are to there to learn and to then to
look at how you would um change other
things that we're doing and certainly
within um the policies that have been um
approved by the legislature for example
when we got this grant there was not 12
months of continuous coverage postpartum
coverage there was not um you've
approved duelas you've approved um don't
lactation Services donor breast milk um
there there there's continuous coverage
for children so there are a lot of
things that have come into play during
this demonstration we're also you know
um working on thinking through how we
can take that demonstration experience
and and I don't have the answer today of
how we're going to U utilize it
completely but you know we're trying to
learn from the model to figure out how
we can with with funding that is no
longer coming from the federal
government to to continue to advance
progress um for for women and their and
their
children thank you
um the the next uh section still on uh
page 14 but on the in the budget book is
88 886 886 the governor's oper yep the
governor's operating
budget and here we're talking about um a
grant that New Hampshire applied for
Medicaid to schools is a program that I
think sometimes gets conflated with
other concerns um out there about what
happens in schools but Medicaid to
schools is really a targeted program um
to help children who have either medical
or disability conditions or both to be
able to accomplish their learning in
school and so for example someone who
might a child that might need insulin uh
shots or medication during the day that
or they might need physical therapy or
or or a rehab assistance to be able to
to uh uh do learning that there's a way
for the the state to uh obtain matching
funds that actually 100% go to the
school
districts so we New Hampshire has had a
claiming methodology um which has been
longstanding that is being phased out by
the federal government by July 1 of 26
we have to be on a new claiming
methodology so we sought this grant um
it uh it's a three-year Grant uh this
represents the first period is in the
budget but ultimately we hope to be able
to draw $2.7 million at at the max um to
be able to support school districts in
transitioning to um a cost based
methodology and the advantage of that
for the school districts
is for those of you who are familiar
with what happens at the county level
the the county nursing homes um are able
to get additional reimbursement to fill
in part of the gap between what Medicaid
pays and and the cost in the nursing
home um that those uncovered costs that
are less than what Medicare would
otherwise pay that we make a a payment
to sort of fill part of that Gap similar
schools can do something similar to that
um where instead of getting the the
contribution that the school is making
towards the the cost which is
50% we we we have historically
administered that as half the fee
schedule represents half the real cost
and I suspect in many instances it's
well below their real costs um and so
this will put them on a on a um platform
where they'll be able to claim half the
cost and um that will I think provide
more funding um and help school
districts and property taxpayers with
the cost of financing these services in
the school environment I also do think
that um it's worthy of some expl
exploration in terms of uh the issue of
me the the the term here I'm looking for
special education what the term I was
looking for is where if you look at and
we'll look at later on some of the the
trends in the using this program have
gone down quite a bit and you know are
there opportunities to work better with
the school districts and in getting um
Medicaid participation instead of having
to be 100% General funds or or what have
you I'm not representing what that might
be but that I do think that's worth uh
exploring
further and um basically this is to fund
the technical support that we need to
implement that program in 174
different um local education
administrative units in in the
state representative priest for a
question yes back on the Medica to
schools Grant how many children are we
um supporting now with the program and
you said it's a three-year program
starting this year so it will end in
2028 uh Medicaid schools program is
longstanding and will continue to
what what we're doing is is getting our
claiming methodology from the federal
government in line with what it needs to
be to continue to claim federal dollars
I see okay and and the big thing that
the federal government wants is they
want to know what costs are and we've
had to switch claiming methodologies in
a number of different areas in in the
state in terms of the Glen Cliff home
New Hampshire hospital um we we've in
reforming the DD population payment
system we've gone to a cost space system
I think as legislators knowing what the
cost of the services are and as a
federal government it's in terms of
looking at the adequacy of funding if
you know what the true cost I think
that's that's I think where the federal
government's going with this but how
many children are we uh providing
services for so I think in our last
report it was just under 9,000 children
had um benefited from it and it has been
a higher number in the past um I think
at its peak we probably were closer to
14 or
15,000 um Medicaid's not an easy um
thing to to master and I think um
hopefully through this grant we'll be
able to help um bring up the
capabilities um in the state so that
those dollars that the state's entitled
to um in the school setting for those
services that support learning um that
will be able to access them and I think
I see that number 9,000 on page 16 of
the out is that the number you're
referring to at the top there
okay okay representative Neno for a
question yes thank you uh Madam chair um
so the change in claiming methodology so
do you anticipate that that's a a net uh
uh plus minus or no no change just
attributable to methodology change is
that you know likely to increase
decrease costs or what's the net impact
of that the net impact is favorable to
the schools in terms of being able to
get a higher level of match because I
think their true costs are higher than
what is recognized in our rates so for
example if you're trying to to uh pay
for a physical therapist who's in the
school setting you might have to
contract with them at $100 an hour or
$100 per certain element and um we may
not be paying enough to to pay someone
at $100 per hour rate and so it will
help close that
Gap thank you okay Mr liman we are at
the one hour point I want to make sure
that uh everybody's comfortable here
it's a very intense topic if you need a
break or anything along that line we are
on page what 16 or so of 70 so you lead
the way Mr Litman but I want to make
sure you're completely at ease here sure
thank you I'm I'm I'm fine okay if you
are and the way the flow of the
questions are going that's okay with you
yes real good and I appreciate the
members being patient I don't have the
benefit of a vice chair to tell me when
a question is waiting so I appreciate
everyone just being patient while I look
around to see if there are questions
thank you you may proceed so page 15 um
and Page um it 887 of the governor's uh
budget um is the adult dental program
and what you're seeing here in this um
page is the adult dental program from
the standard program there there's also
the adult dental program goes into
granted Advantage um the the dollars to
cover the adult dental program today um
from 2023 through um we anticipate
through this whole B Anum the state had
a uh a settlement with one of the MCO
companies um that is providing 100% of
the the state share um you know for that
time
period so the the dollars that are
represented here are those coming from
that settlement and a federal match if
you'll notice it's also gone down um you
know when we first scoped out the
program we didn't know how many dentist
would actually enroll in the
program um we've we've grown up to over9
0 dentists in the program um we've also
um used mobile Dental Services fully
equipped uh Dental uh uh oper operating
environments which include a dentist and
um staff that we actually even some uh
many weekends were providing Dental
access on Saturday and Sunday um at
different locations throughout the state
where we have a shortage of of dental
providers uh but uh what reflect here is
an expectation of where we think we are
based on actual experience um Delta
Dental has been an excellent partner in
terms of working with us and trying to
to grow the the dental network and we're
hoping over time that we'll continue to
see growth and be able to serve people
but what's in here is what we reasonably
expect based on where we are today
representative Stringham for a question
so according to uh the brief um the
budget uh the actual
expenditures uh in uh 2024 were about 11
and half million and you're projecting
7.2 million now and it would seem like
there would have been more uh providers
online was there just huge penup demand
and or what is there any uh any
explanation for you know 30 40% decrease
in Services sure so I I I'm not I think
I need to go back and look at why it's
showing up as actual expense that year
but when I'm looking at today's expense
expenditures year to date we've seen
about 22 million of expenditures year-to
date in this state fiscal year which is
much more consistent with the amounts
that we've budgeted in subsequent years
is that um is that all funds or or or
just general funds that's total well
there are no General funds in this
accounting units is federal and the
other funds from the centine
settlement so um one of the things we
did which I think was an excellent
business practice is
and um if you follow the news in some
other states we actually put a minimum
medical loss ratio or dental loss ratio
to make sure that if they didn't spend a
certain amount of money that anything um
below above below excuse me below that
ratio would come back to the state so I
think what's not reflected in there yet
in the actual experience is that we are
going to get a refund on on
that representative tarki for question
thanks um I just sort of have an
anecdotal um perspective of the adult
dental program when I see constituents
comment on like a local Facebook page
saying I can't find a provider that
takes the program now there's obviously
a very large demand I do know the
program has been successful where it can
actually be utilized do you have any
idea of what we actually need in terms
of number of providers to provide the
service that's actually needed
um I can give you an answer but I'd
rather consult with a dental director to
to give you a more precise answer but I
do think that
um we we are seeing an increasing number
of individuals and if someone is having
a problem that you know of as a
constituent please call me and we'll um
you know we we have actually um when we
do the mobile sites we have lists of
people who we can call last minute like
you see dental office sometimes do that
um we're you know they're on standby if
someone else doesn't show up that we can
fill that space so um I think we're
doing all all we can um to ex extend it
and I think it's going to be with time
that um you know other dentists will
will hopefully join the program I think
New Hampshire's fortunate we now have
the president of the Ada for the for the
country is now a dentist from New
Hampshire so I'm hoping that we can
continue to build the network
we I think that we'd like to see have
seen it even better but i' say based on
what we've done it's it's gone pretty
well there's still room to grow and
improve great thank you for that
representative nil vano followed by
representative
Stringham just a a quick question so
this is uh preventative care as as
preventative care as well as you know um
I'll call emergency care or there's um
we can provide you with what the the um
coverages But it includes preventative
care includes fillings it includes it
does not include uh know like gum
surgery per se but it what you would
typically find in a commercial Dental uh
benefit um you would see in this program
but we actually in the legislation
there's specific uh that adopted the
program there's some exclusion of
certain services but for example the um
people in waiver people in nursing home
have access to Dentures um as part of
this program so you know the one of the
things that can cause a person to
deteriorate is not being able to eat
right and so um again the um with the
leadership from the legislature there
was a a willingness to add um Dentures
for certain populations um other
populations were excluded
just just very quick so that's the
preventative care would be I think
typically two two checkups a year y
cleanings
and it's I think it's a it's a program
that many people worked hard on for many
many years decades even to bring about
and um I think we're we're fortunate uh
what we're able to deliver here um the
next uh representative Stringham uh just
if you could share um not not today but
if you have anything about the rates and
whether there's been any feedback from
providers who have signed up of whether
the uh rates are adequate for them uh
you know to to take the Medicaid
patients over others that may come to
their doors I'd appreciate it we can do
that if I could comment though that when
you did the the rate increases in HB 2
of 2023
um we were able to make our children's
and adult Dental rates I think probably
you know very competitive what other
Medicaid programs um are able to pay um
I think we're probably somewhere around
72% on average of the the commercial
market in terms of the rate for dental
services
today and just on the all set just on
the topic of the sentin settlement it
would appear that that is uh a pilot
program is that fair to say um well I
think it I I don't think it would be
fair to call a pilot it's a it's the
funding that I think that was available
to get this program over the Finish Line
If you will
legislatively it remains to be seen once
that's run out whether you know it will
continue but we're hoping it does well
that leads to my next question uh it
would seem in the circumstance that data
is needed uh for future budgets and uh
anything you could provide related to
that would be helpful sure so at this
point in time at the end of the bium
we're we're projecting about a $960,000
u balance of the centine funds so we we
anticipate having sufficient other funds
to support the program through this bium
but um beginning in the next bium we
will we will need to address that that
question of how will this program be
funded going
forward thank you and that's where I
think the data will be very helpful and
terms of future budgeting for the
continuation of said program we do make
regular reports to Health and Human
Service oversight that we can share that
with this committee as well in terms of
that type of
information perfect thank you
representative priest for a question
thank you madam chairman again that
number of unused funds going to be
applied for
this so so the we we're projecting for
the end of State fiscal year 25 about
about $
11.5 U
million and then at the end of the
subsequent bium about $950,000
but again that'll depend on
utilization okay thank
you go ahead Mr Litman thank you um
bottom of page uh 15 is the children's
health insurance program which uh oops
of course
my computer is not
responding that begins on um page eight
uh 900 um towards the bottom goes on to
uh
901 um if you're a member of fiscal
committee um you may have heard this
morning that we had a transfer into this
um account uh that we made we we began
separately um accounting for the
children's health insurance program
where we get the enhanced Federal match
separately the time we made the original
projections and starting to do this we
had a few things that came up that
weren't anticipated like the federal
Public Health Emergency and continuous
enrollment we also had um a federal
requirement to cover children for 12
months continuously so I think based on
going into this budget we have a better
sense of of the experience and um we're
also reflective in here I think is a
point where
um uh number two
um comes into play uh that was on the
the sheet earlier in terms of the the
ultimate costs that will be incurred
here you want to address that just for
clarification here we are on page
890 of the governor's budget at this
point um 9901 is what I have uh 8
yeah so so the the children's health
insurance program accounting unit is
7051 it begins on page
887 and then it continues on to
888 great sorry I gave you the PDF
okay okay proceed so I think what we're
we're seeing here in part is what's
factored into the governor's budget is
um revenue from um premiums and we are
um going to make a budget adjustment in
terms of How It's in budget adjustment
request what we feel is the the the
revenue that's brought in from premiums
should be shown as a revenue as opposed
to netting it into the expenses but the
effect is ultimately the the same um
what we're anticipating
in Revenue um or which is effectively
expense reduction is about 3.3 3 million
in the first year and about 11 million
in the second year and the reason
there's a difference between the two
years it'll take a little time to
implement and then there'll be we have
to phase it in based on where people are
on their coverage and their 12- month
continuous coverage and the eligibility
level um that's in here is so we go up
to 323 per of of the federal poverty
limit that's not changed in this what is
has changed is that whereas we have no
premiums today only cost sharing on
Pharmacy that um there would be premium
starting at
25% of the poverty limit that not being
the child but the family income um and
um premiums by federal law are capped at
5% of family income
um and so um what Our intention is also
from the standpoint if this is the
policy that ultimately is
enacted is to um since the maximum
someone could be uh we have to keep
track of what what they've incurred in
claims if someone's paying premiums we
won't have other cost sharing because
otherwise we'd have to make an an
investment in our it structure that that
that we can avoid by keeping it simple
and that's that's uh what we're talking
about here um you know in terms of other
states that you know nearby um uh
Massachusetts and and New York are two
states that are um have premiums but you
go across the country there are about 18
states currently that have uh premiums
with children at one point it was I
think as high as 26 New Hampshire did
have premiums back um when children's
health insurance was provided to the
health through the healthy kids
Corporation um and the at that time the
premum started at 186% of poverty um and
also um that there was both cost sharing
and and premiums I think we're trying to
keep it simpler and less costly to to
implement if that's what ends up being
um enacted um and let me stop there
because I see there are people who I
think want to representative walner
followed by representative tarki but it
looks like Mr White just wants to
interject here would you yield
representative Walder sure I I I I just
want to add up point of clarity so in in
the governor's recommended budget there
was a reduction of $3.3 million in state
fiscal year 26 of General funds and
reduction of $1 million of General funds
in state fiscal year
2027 if if it's the committee's desire
to keep this policy um we would
recommend a change re it's a technical
change request to increase the other
Revenue by the equivalent amounts as
well as the expenditures there was just
a technical issue um in the reduction
where we reduced both the general funds
and the expenditures but we didn't
increase increase the other Revenue to
recognize that so um I can provide the
change request if the committee uh
chooses to take this direction
representive walner thank you could you
go into a little bit more detail about
how this premium would be collected I I
actually served on the board of
directors of healthy kids I was the
legislative um appointment to that and I
remember the board
struggling in the situation of the
collection of the
premium and families that didn't have it
we were we tried to do fundraising to
help subsidize families that couldn't
couldn't come up with a premium so would
you kind of talk through and what
happens when a family doesn't pay the
premium or the check bounces or you know
and how will they be able to come back
on on at some point what's what what's
going to happen here so your last
question is the easiest one to answer
which is as I mentioned earlier that
Medicaid's continuously open so if
someone does close um they can apply
again um the um in terms of the the the
method of collecting the premiums um we
have some thoughts about that in terms
of how we would sort of set that up we
what I'm trying to do in approaching
that is has come up with a simple
solution so it's the cost of
implementing it is doesn't consume all
of the the the potential Revenue um you
know there there are
ways that I think um potentially
exploring some systems that the state
already has or or or vendor where you
would work for a percentage of um what
you collected to provide a a
infrastructure to be able to make
payments or a is from a checking account
I mean the issue of people who don't pay
is some a policy Development Area that
we need to work on um we haven't um um
we haven't gotten that far to be um you
know transparent about that but we know
that we're going to have to develop
policies around what happens if someone
doesn't pay and um you know what I can
say is that you know we'll have to look
at what is um allowable and in terms of
the federal law on those types of things
and um we have factored into our
estimate of dollars that it isn't
collectible representative walner so how
many families fall above that what was
it
correct uh which is about
8600 um8 600 8600 children families it
might be more children yeah it's we're
figuring about 10% of the the the the
children that are in the program that
would apply to okay you know this is
just a question I have about all of this
when a um 86,000 children someone can't
pay the premium or they let it lapse or
whatever
happens and they are in the midst of
some medical
really serious medical issue cancer or
some other you know kind of thing what
happens at that point they just are they
lose it and then they have to go so I
think we have some policy design choices
about that um we encounter that today
sometimes where someone may be so
destitute that they can't get their
medication um and so we do have some
policies and that's what I was saying I
think um you know this is fairly new to
us as well in the department in terms of
you know developing um the strategy but
you know I think we'll be transparent
about what it's going to look like um
and um you know I I do think we have to
take into consideration people under
active treatment and you can't just drop
them um so I think that's part of the
when we were doing our estimation we
didn't assume that 100% of the the
premium potentially could be collected
so um I'd rather not you know speculate
on what that's going to be until we
develop the policies
and just one one last
question 5% of a of a family income at
that at the level of 255 per of poverty
is really substantial I tried last night
to do some math and I mean it you know
it's a
family's car payment it's their you know
a portion of their rent it's their child
care expense
um do you see any other any other
mechanisms for helping these families
pay these these premiums I think that
you're going to we're going to see a
number of families that are just not
going to be able to do it again I think
there are a lot of issues to work
through to implement this and you're
identifying a number of them today I
don't have all the answers today to be
you know totally
transparent thank you representative
tarki followed by representative
Stringham followed by representative
nven go thank you thank you very much
for taking my question well to follow up
on what representative walner was
getting at I did dig into some math a
little bit on this and I used a
hypothetical single mom with two kids
who is at
25% of the poverty level which means she
makes
cents a year and
$283 15 a month so just although we
don't have answers on how it's going to
work let's assume that she has to pay a
premium of
$283 15 a month am I correct so
far I know you can't answer I'm going to
assume that that's accurate up to this
point um
so is it true though as representative
walner stated that that's for many
families a car payment um which would
get her to work to be able to pay for
this in the first place um that if she
had to if she got dropped for whatever
reason due to something uh catastrophic
injury whatever she just didn't have the
that money to pay her $283 a month um
isn't it true that with an increase of
care compensated care because she let's
say is going to still need that
emergency care treatment she has to
bring her child who broke his arm to the
ER and that child is no longer covered
that in the end that raises the cost for
the state
significantly and that this $1 million a
year that we are quote saving is
actually going to be significantly
more I guess in terms of the the
scenario that you talked about there was
a of it I just want to clarify um I
thought I heard and I may not have heard
correctly that um where her income
changed at some point were you making
that no I I misheard then no she
couldn't afford to pay the cost share of
whatever the 5% if it's weekly monthly
and so she got dropped which we don't
know what that actually means what it
looks
like so I think you know the number I
had in my head in terms of was at at a
single at one person which is you know
your 283 calculation I can run the
number for you well we're talking about
chips so I did a mom with kids yeah yeah
no I know I'm just saying in my head the
number I had I'm just having some for
the scenario you gave um you know I I do
think that
um you know in many I would say this
about the state budget in many instances
there are times when the state um may or
may not cover something and that it's
picked up in either e by the federal
government or by the local government or
by the individual and I think what what
this policy does is is asking
individuals of a certain income to to
share in the cost of of it and um I
think you know in terms of our estimate
that's that's within the governor's
budget it does not assume that 100% of
that is going to be to be paid there are
going to be circumstances like you arise
there where we're going to have to to
develop policies to to accommodate
certain situations but some cost will be
passed on to other areas I think that's
a fair fair statement to make
potentially um how much of that I can't
can't represent today until we have some
experience thank you representative
Stringham followed by representative
Neno well I guess we all use different
numbers because I had a family of four
but came out to 350 a month um but uh
the question I just had I guess there
are mechanisms for for handling uh
patients without health insurance uh we
have facilities that are required uh as
part of their Charter hospitals and uh U
federally qualified um uh centers uh
that they they take patients in need
regardless of their financial ability
and somehow they have to get um uh money
that they never are able to collect uh
somehow they get paid in and I think
part of that is through uh uncomp
uncompensated care fund so I I would
just ask you know um so um you know I
think the savings that that we would
have from collecting is going to be
partially offset by those that don't get
into the program and then uh become
consumers in the uncompensated care fund
so uh I know you you you said you're not
an e economic modeling modeler but I I
just wonder to what degree um um you
know those you know secondary effects of
this policy change have have been um
thought through and and reduced in
numbers and if not today they happy to
if if if you have anything you can share
it uh after this hearing well I think
certainly we can talk to additional
States about what their experience has
been um I can say that they many states
that have continued to have you know
this Premium cost sharing um you know I
think that you know other structures for
for dealing with reducing the budget for
example you could put it all in co-pays
but then you have a problem with
collections at the provider level which
could create U access barriers so I
think um you know to the extent that um
the budget requires us to have
participation of of individuals that
there is some aspects of this that that
are going to play out in certain ways
and I guess you know we'll we'll U we'll
do some more work on that thank
you yeah I'm going to jump jump from the
micro back to you know the macro
so and correct me if I'm wrong on this
but the demographics in New Hampshire
we've seen it's an aging population and
if I'm correct I think the birth rate is
is dropping at least nationally is that
the same for New Hampshire and then the
question is how how that figures into
the the budgeting process from the
standpoint of not only the birth rate
changing but probably
demographically on where the births are
falling in you know relative to the uh
cutof rates on on
income so so do we see you know we're
certainly seeing a shifting to the
elderly uh end of uh Medicaid and
Medicare so are we seeing some kind of a
shift in the other direction on the uh
youth side of this so in terms of birth
rate um the last report I saw on that
was New Hampshire actually had
stabilized and was one of the few states
that hadn't declined now there may be
another year of data that I have not
observed yet but that was coming um out
of the pandemic that um but you know our
our births are been pretty consistent
around 11 to 12,000 a year for quite a
bit of time but you know
when we look at some other information
this in this uh slide deck compared to
other states even our neighbors like
Vermont and Maine New
Hampshire generally has a higher
economic status that gets reflected in
the federal share that those states are
paid New Hampshire um standard Medicaid
is reimbursed at
50% other states are um like um M uh
Maine and and Vermont are above that
number um and I have a chart later on
here that gives you an actual comparison
look up the page number for um that uh
we actually can demonstrate to you that
I think that you know New
Hampshire has been able to support the
fifth highest eligibility level at 323
per. the national average is
255 um and so you know we probably do
have more families that are um um I'll
uh representative n vano if you could
just uh maybe move your microphone
closer to you I just want to be sure
that YouTube and everybody watching and
all this and sees this in the future
picks up what you say thank you
um David help me find a page
U uh actually that's not the one I was
looking for I was looking for to the map
that compares the different states in
the region yeah
yes yeah page page 50 uh of the slide
deck you can see um there's a map on the
Le hand side and then a comparison of
different States Federal matching
percentages you can see Maine um was
over 60% and Veron is just under 60%
which is you know when you count that
times billions is a lot of money
um we're we're in the same company as
Connecticut and and Massachusetts in
terms of our federal match even Rhode
Island we're we're more well off than
Rhode Island um with respect to how the
federal match
Works
um so just just a quick call follow so
the the poverty rate here is
comparatively better than than some of
the surrounding surrounding States but
when you factor into you know I'm
looking thinking about the demographics
of where the child births are coming
relative to the um income levels you
know again trying to get at what the
what the macro Trends look like in terms
of this overall program looks you know
is it having a a downward slope on it
compared to when we look at Medicare and
Medicaid on the elderly side of it we
might be seeing an upward slope so so I
think um in terms of macro Trend I think
the the wealth the economic wealth of
the state on a per capita basis has
improved and we are seeing fewer kids as
a percentage of the entire program just
as you see fewer kids in school there
there's there's a bit of a trend there
but not not that discernable if you will
um it definitely is not upward in terms
of the number of children in the
program thank you
representative priest for question yes
um by chance do you have any information
any data of showing the children who are
in the program versus those that would
qualified but for some reason are not in
the
program I I don't but I'm suspecting
there may be some information out there
that we could research that could help
address that um I would really like that
that are folks okay if we move to the
next yes we're now going to page we're
going to page 16 of the deck and um 888
of
the the governor's operating
budget and um in Medicaid schools we
talked earlier about the grant here
we're talking about um the actual
program that exists and
um as I mentioned before um I think this
is a an area where um we have seen a
shrinkage in the program um utilization
I think for a couple of reasons I think
the pandemic had a great effect on on
schools uh but also you know to be
compliantly participating in the
Medicaid Program that in 201819
time frame
um the if you will the rules that
schools need to follow got a little bit
more um complex for them to follow um
and um I think some schools may not be
um have the technical expertise to to
master the program and so I think the
grant could be helpful to to turning
that tide sum and
um um you know I think here we're we
have uh budgeted for an increase I think
that hb2 language in Prior sessions has
allowed the the department to come back
to request additional funds if need be
they're 100% federal funds um I
understood um the other day you
discussed this point um about you know
wanting to monitor what is happening in
this program we we'd recommend I think
reporting over um other means to sort of
track what's going on we we you know we
report once a year we certainly could
report you know quarterly if that was a
preference as opposed to having to enact
legislation but you know we'll work with
with um any questions on this
Representative
walner no I should know this how does
how does the school districts
um the school is are is paying a portion
of these services and then a portion
comes through Medicaid schools how do
you account for that so so um it's
actually quite simple today um good they
they provide a service like a physical
therapy treatment they they bill us like
any other provider would bill us often
schools are using a billing company to
support them but they send in a claim we
pay half the claim and the other half is
assumed to be their contribution okay um
for the federal match and that's what I
was getting at earlier is I think our
rate our rates may not really
approximate half their costs and so I
think other states that have converted
to the methodology that will be required
for us to be have seen a benefit to
their schools in terms of what they're
able to get in Medicaid funding okay
you would it be okay if I mve to the
next
so we're going to Medicaid
Administration which is
7937 and on 889 and this one is one
where I'd really like to to uh give some
Concepts here um the largest line item
which is on um 049 transfer to other
state agencies this is really not an
administrative expense of of the
Medicaid um division it represents the
the federal claiming to pay um New
Hampshire hospital and historically um
Glen cliff and also Hamstead before it
changes and the reason you see the
reduction between um the current years
and going into 26 and 27 is Hamstead
will no longer be eligible for this type
of funding but basically we're drawing a
federal match for the uncompensated care
disproportionate share funding and we
transfer once we make the claim it goes
so it's really if you will not we're not
incurring an
expense here um the other thing I'd like
to say about this unit um and we'll have
a little bit more detail on this later
on is in terms of our contract lines
we've made a 25%
reduction um in our contract expenses uh
for uh this upcoming bium in in the
governor's budget
and I'll also point out there are a
couple of really important contracts
that have rois of 15 times their cost
and one of them one of the expenses in
this line is our how we generate our
Pharmacy rebate it's our vendor that we
pay to generate Pharmacy rebate we pay a
little under
$200,000 and we're going to bring in you
know 30 million roughly and rebates or
maybe more
um we have um a contractor who um checks
the um the spending of the mco's uh
medical loss ratio and we we um there we
have a vendor that's I gave that I gave
the example of was um we spend a little
under $200,000 a year on that vendor and
bring in um you know like $3 million in
the the current year I meant previously
to say in the pharmacy side we spend a
little under two million and get 30
million sorry I complained those two for
a moment um but generally what we're
seeing here is that the contracts that
we're entering into are ones that are
generating value to the state the other
big item in this area is our actuary um
to help us develop our rates and on both
the the medical side and the dental side
you know it's the largest contracts that
the state enters into um you know a
point or two of accuracy is real money
um and
um that one I think the return on
investment there is not as easy to
calculate but I think you know we've
been pretty consistent of being able to
work within the means of of the Medicaid
Program in this area and you know with a
very very small margin um to to account
for um a
variance um I'll stop there and see if
there are any
questions representative Stringham for a
question yeah just on on the contractual
program services you find that there's
any areas uh in there within those
contracts where you could both improve
quality and uh and increase efficiency
by bringing some of the work inhouse
rather than doing it through contracts
and if so where would that be so the
three major ones that I um gave as
example the the pharmacy rebates no I
think that's a A specialized technology
area and the medical loss ratio no
because I think the these companies do
this every day and an actuary our
actuary is the largest actuary in the
Medicaid space in the country they do 30
States and you know that I just don't
think we would being operating alone
would have that level of expertise um
you know we we do I think a good amount
of work with our our team um both in
finance and um and and Medicaid that
that we can do um but that there's very
little dollars here that I think um
would work in that
fashion and and I I I think it's um also
just to highlight this um because we
were talking about hb2 earlier so in
that in that 102 contract um there there
is an impact of an hb2 provision that
will be in the final hb2 that comes out
and what what that's doing there is
effectively over the bium reducing that
line by a million dollars it's 500,000
each year it's 5050 and and it's a
directive to um reduce the the um the
Actuarial contract um so that we only
conduct One Rate adjustment each year uh
typically we do two rate adjustments one
at the end of the state fiscal year one
around December time frame and so um
there was about a million dollars total
funds and cost savings generated by that
hb2 provision and that's been reflected
line representative Neno thank you Madam
chair so just just so I understand so to
the extent that the you have the savings
that is that showing up as a net number
in the in the contract line or do the
savings you know the refunds like I
guess in particular so you cited a
couple of vendors that result in um uh
one was a refund on the I guess the
prescription drugs and the the rebates
show up in a a different spot uh the
drug rebates um and and what about the
other savings uh so on the um the uh the
medical loss ratio in the dental program
or the MCM program that would um come
down to net the expenses and in those
areas so one of them is already
reflected in the the the numbers that
you've got in there and the cost and the
other one shows up somewhere else yeah
so the the rebate savings in accounting
unit
07 what where would I find that in what
page it's on page of the governor's
operating budget
891 um we we we will be going through
that so we can certainly talk about that
rebate Revenue when we get there though
that's
easier okay and 892 but we'll get to
that as you
say okay all set to proceed okay
thank you so um going to 8 um the very
bottom of 888 8889 to
890 um state phase down um which is on
the top of slide
um so in the Medicaid Program there are
certain seniors um who also have
Medicare coverage um we call them duly
eligible for Medicaid and Medicare
um the state picks up uh some of their
cost for prescription drugs um and that
amount that has to be picked up is by
each state for these people who are duly
eligible is a number that we don't get
to decide it's a it's a if you will like
a premium we have to pay um and
um we are paying um
and the amount that we end up having to
pay is unfortunately not in sync with
the the budget so we make our best
estimate the last increase I think was
8% as you know prescription drugs if you
have a Part D premium um they're not
going down um and uh so in part we've
made our best best case estimate if I'm
remembering correctly we're paying about
$273 today for on a on a monthly basis
per person for that coverage for those
individuals
yep just so um it is um it's it's one of
those expenses that we
really states do not have an ability to
control other than through trying to
keep their people healthy if you will
and the amount of drugs that in number
of people on the program representative
priest for a question and then
representative Stringham thank you madam
chairman on page
889 on item 049 transfer to other state
agencies what is that um so earlier I
was mentioning that the uncompensated
care or disproportionate share funds
that are paid to New Hampshire hospital
Glen Cliffe um and formerly Hamstead
that's where those transfers run through
so it's really as I was saying it's not
an an administrative expense per se it's
just
the accounting of where the how the
money comes in and then gets paid
out and and when we get to New Hampshire
hospital and glencliffe in a couple of
weeks you will see the corresponding
item right you had reviewed that earlier
um it's a
little a little deceiving uh but thank
you for that clarification okay
representative Stringham followed by
representative tarki in terms of the
Medicaid um uh program in the far
Pharmacy um do you have any flexibility
uh on um uh what drugs are included uh
what price you pay uh whether there's a
a cap per patient uh you know how
restrictive is the federal program and
do you have to be in this program to be
part of of Medicaid in
general so I think going back to the the
number three on that list sort of gets
to a little bit to that that um under
New Hampshire law there's a a
requirement to use generics first which
I think generally would make sense um
except in the world of Medicaid where um
rebates are um are larger and so what
we're asking for um in legislation I
think Senate Bill 119 I believe is a
version and the governor is asking in
her budget is to include this and I
think when I was watching representative
Daniels you had a question does that
increase the cost of the federal
government actually lowers it um because
they pay their Federal share so if
there's less expense for the state the
amount that the federal government would
have to pay would be less as well so
it's a I think a double win if you will
um and
um so what that we're asking for it's
not always the case that with rebate
that we're asking to allow the
department to where it is more favorable
to the state and to overall healthare
cost to be able to to to access a brand
name drug so getting to your question um
regarding there are in order to
participate in the federal rebate
program you do have to have on your
formulary access to um FDA approved
drugs that being said states can develop
utilization criteria there's a a runway
for States I think typically six months
before they'd have to included in their
formulary you can develop different
criteria you know you're not forced to
just hand out pills um it's it's can be
based on you know appropriate U clinical
um utilization criteria you know
medicine in the Medicaid
Program has grown since I've been in the
Medicaid director a little over seven
years when I first came in it was about
18% of the medical spend today it's
31% so it's an area in the and when we
did the reprocurement that we
restructured how um the state shares
that risk with um the the
mcos there's also um when I first
started the program up until two or
three years ago there'd be like one or
two of these very expensive um Gene
therapies or biological
treatments um last year when we
developed our budget uh or excuse me um
in 20 24 Managed Care rates there were
66 new therapies of over
$100,000 and there the velocity of these
coming at us are incredibly High um and
uh you know we've fortunately um you
know have not a lot of these are for
rare conditions um but they're um all
jenma as an example of it that acquiring
that um that uh therapy before
for rebate the cost of the therapy alone
is $2.4 million for treatment now what
that does is a child that has duan's
distrophy
they won't have it and think about what
the lifetime cost of caring for someone
for 20 or more years um and you have to
get it in a certain interval for it to
be effective you have in that one
particular one need it by five or after
five it doesn't work so
um they these are very important issues
to to individuals who have these rare
conditions and that's why we want to run
the program um not just efficiently but
effectively so that we can bring the
therapies that would bring benefit to
the public but also to you know manage
our costs the best we can excuse me I
think I'm e need some more
water sure uh we do have questions in
the queue representative tarki followed
by Representative no Nelco um we're now
at the 3:00 just about the 3:00 Mark I
see we're on slide 17 just want to make
sure you're running like you want to be
running I I think we're getting through
the important parts and and we're almost
done through the governor's um budget a
lot of the rest of the material can move
a lot faster I think okay and let us
I'm talking too
much as expected yeah okay
representative tersi representative
Neno you're onk you thank you I want to
thank you again for the amount of time
you're and information you're giving us
this is not an easy task um I originally
had raised my hand because I wanted to
um continue to bring attention to the
mystery document here cuz I thought we
were hitting bullet three appears I was
correct
um can you just clarify though um that
this section on the acquisition of um
generic and name brand drugs is already
included in the hb2 trailer Bill draft
that we have seen yes it is okay thank
is representative Neno yeah I just want
to take the opportunity to again thank
you for the presentation materials it's
uh uh difficult to follow this stuff
jumping from one document to another but
I think this uh presents it in a way
that uh we can cross reference the the
material to the various documents and uh
my question is on
890 uh and probably this is the same
kind of a question and I you know just
wasn't paying attention but I'll I'll
ask it anyhow the the drop in the
hospital uncompensated carepool is just
a shift from one place to another is
that
yes I think this is probably the most
we're we're we're dealing now with the
uncompensated care fund 7943 thank you
very much yeah that's right line line
515 on I guess 890 so so the concept
here um and one of the I think questions
that we received um from Committee
Member um what you see playing out here
is how The uncompensated CARE program is
evolving um the
um at one
point um and for many for decades
actually um at least two New Hampshire
would um uh collect through the Dr the
department of retive administration
What's called the Medicaid enhancement
tax um or assessment it's basically a
5.4% um on on Hospital services and by
Hospital services it's as defined in a
Medicare cost report as Hospital
Services um and that money um comes to
the to this department Via de the
Department of Revenue
Administration the state makes a federal
claim on that at
50% and then a portion of that
historically has been
91% would come back to hospitals not
each one getting 91% of what they paid
but based on the amount of uncompensated
care they would tap into the
pool um over time
um uh rules around this have changed
federally it's become advantageous to um
what's not paid out to the to the
hospitals helps support other providers
um and and then that 7948 account and
and
others and supports the Medicaid program
so 9% of the of the amount equivalent
amount is comes to the state as if you
will an extra to the to the 50% match
they
had um that 16 RSA
167 um I think 18 is where you find the
the law that's um that sort of governs
um
the how how this money is is handled
and paid to the hospitals today it today
the the the language and the law doesn't
Define exactly it it defines about how
the money comes in how it's protected um
but the percentages that come out is
something that has evolved there was a
an agreement that was codified in um
legislation in 2018 that legislation
expired last session there was an
attempt to come up with a new new
agreement um there was not an agreement
that and then the governor and
commissioner have
um the what we you might under have
heard about an 80% of the federal match
coming back to the to the uh hospitals
as opposed to
91% so getting back directly to your
question and what you're seeing in the
numbers here is that it's been
advantageous not to
pay to all the parties not to pay out
the money through traditional
uncompensated care um but to pay it
through um related to Medicaid services
and the uncomp uncompensated care
associated with that and um people who
have no
insurance and and what we've done here
is that we've increased for example on
Hospital rates and patient
rates um the the amount that um went
from say the average um case have gone
from like um 3500 today we're paying
over 9,000 where that difference is
coming is Shifting it from uncompensated
care category here to um provider rates
in
7948 what that allows us to draw is a
higher Federal match on those on those
dollars which makes more money available
to support the Medicaid Program and more
available to work out in The
uncompensated CARE program in terms of
the
the percentage that each party gets in
that that's that I think is still
subject to you know in the governor's
budget it's it's 80% that's where um it
stands today I'm expecting that um
there'll be more conversations in the
legislature and and with the governor
and the hospitals about this topic but
what's represented here today is the
80% approach and what that means is some
of the dollars that would appear as
going out at that 50% % match are now in
the other parts of the budget 7948 being
the largest that where we're paying out
higher rates as opposed to uncompensated
care so instead of getting a 50% match
we might get closer to a 60% match in
the granted Advantage
space um our match is 90% and paying out
in rates um there um the match instead
of being 50 is 90 and so some of what's
formerly this account is now um in in
granted
Advantage um which is to say this is
hard to hard to follow um because one
we're we're U moving dollars to the area
where it's most advantageous in terms of
the total pool of money and secondly
that there there's a part of the money
that is now part of granted Advantage um
but that's all um we can all account for
all of it and we can certainly
demonstrate it but I just as you're
looking at this say why are numbers
changing so much it's because of that
Dynamic that's playing out right now in
2025 and and will play out in 26
27 okay we have represent just a real
quick so are you using an algorithm or
something to optimize this looks like a
some kind of a subprogram to to optimize
the The Matrix there a you will
well actually no but um it's sort of
like uh solving simultaneous equations
because give you an example if you're a
border hospital and the uncompensated
care is based only on Medicaid when you
pay out pure uncompensated care you can
I can pay we can pay a hospital for New
Hampshire Medicaid patients
uncompensated care and let's say Vermont
or Massachusetts that we can draw a
federal match on that when you pay it
out in Rat you can only pay it for New
Hampshire
patients in um the design of the the
payment plan we've come up with other
ways of adjusting for that we've worked
with the hospital Association on
modifiers for like border hospitals to
account for some of that but in the end
um you know from the hospitals
perspective anyways that
um certain hospitals it's better for
them to get
um some of their dollars in the the
traditional way because it you can still
pay the traditional way to all types of
uncompensated care related to uninsured
and and
Medicaid um it's it's something we're
spending have spent a lot of time on
trying to optimize but it's not an
algorithm it's more of um formul best
fit if you will there's more art than
science there Art and Science yes okay
we're going to go representative Daniels
then representative Stringham then
representative walner then
representative priest thank you uh you
you may have answered the question I'm
I'm not quite sure okay sure that I had
uh but when when you talk about the
uncompensated pay you're paying for the
unpaid cost of care who is determining
that cost is it the hospital that says
this aspirin cost
$43 or is it the uh Medicaid that says
it's 29 cents and what happens with the
uninsured so the the cost C is
determined through a cost report that
it's a a standard Report with standard
rules um it's the same report that
Medicare uses to determine what the
actual cost is and then the costs and
the uncompensated part is that the state
also hires an auditor we're required to
hire an auditor to audit what the
hospitals are representing as their
costs and the way that this program
actually works is so that there's not a
delay in compensating for uncompensated
care we make an estimate of what
uncompensated care is and then we
reconcile it some period later because
on compensation as you could expect
sometimes it takes a while for that to
play out someone may pay their bill over
time um it may not um may not be
apparent within a very short period of
time what it is so there's it's a it's
something that's fairly complex we have
technical support on that on a weekly
basis that we work with and and U it's a
highly um sophisticated it's probably
the most difficult part of the Medicaid
Program to to comprehend and it takes a
team of people to to work it but you
know we are audited by the federal
government as well on our Audits and
there are there are rules on this and
there's been litigation over time that
have changed the
rules but you know just in terms of
today's conversation I think that the
uncompensated care that we're providing
is is is a standard definition and it is
not only looked at by us but looked at
by an outside auditor who's representing
the federal government and how much
they're paying ultimately it seems to be
based on the Medicare fee schedule
Medicare cost finding yes okay thank
you yeah thank you um the 7948 is that
impatient Hospital services or 7948
covers the a lot of just the Managed
Care Program um is the Lion Share of
that which pays providers so the the
kind of rates that that uh have I mean
La two years ago when we we adjusted
Medicaid rates we left hospitals
untouched at
0% um but uh uh now now it looks like
we've we've done a shift from of 80
million or so from the uncompensated
care fund to additional Medicaid rates
uh I guess through the Managed Care
provision uh and um and how how how much
did those rates go you said something
about 3,000 to 9,000 or was that just a
random uh a hypothetical example we we
went if I know you're familiar with this
for drg rate of one was around 3,000
it's now what Med was at the time set at
Medicare levels which is closer to 9,000
something at the
time and um uh same patient rates I was
referring to yeah so uh
um uh is is the combination of these two
things uh in your view adequate to keep
uh uh hospitals um uh solvent and and
whole at this point or we still still
kind of uh going through uh uh
additional adjustments I can say that
the hospitals have testified you know as
recently as um earlier this week that
they don't feel that the the 80% plan is
sufficient and obviously they're doing
quite a bit of advocacy work to try to
um so I do understand you know that that
instead of getting a 50% match we're now
getting a blended rate the granted
Advantage 90% rate and the 50% rate for
standard Medicaid managed care what what
does that come out to be um it uh it's
probably close to 60% and it it varies
but there's one other feature here that
in addition to higher rates um we've
used another concept called directed
payments which is effectively paying a
higher rate as well but we're allowed
particularly um we've converted to this
with the critical access hospitals to be
able to get them the most that is where
we're able to pay them based on an
average commercial rate ultimately it's
capped at something like that and so um
it can go even above Medicare in that
instance
um great thank
you representative
walner just because I couldn't
follow where where all the uh funds were
were going in those in the um 515
line can you maybe do a little chart for
us at some point that would show us that
we're going to find some of these now
over in you know adult and wherever
wherever they've moved to yes yes we can
absolutely do that I I I I think one of
the easiest places to start is if you
look at on page 890 in accounting unit
7943 the5 private local funds so that
that's the that's the Met Revenue that's
coming in and you'll see you'll see that
decrease from 25 adjusted authorized to
26 on page 890 and accounting unit 794 3
and then if you if you turn the page and
you look at uh
7948 you you'll see that that increase
in met Revenue in the 005 line there
where it goes up to
283 so so basically I think that you
know just quick math it's about 327
million okay in in the uh first year of
the next bium and we did incre we did
include some increases based on the
trends that that we've seen year to dat
um over the past uh couple of years so
great thank you of
course representative priest for
question yes just as a a again a
clarification on uh again on page
891 on the uncompensated care
fund um you mentioned that there are
transfers out of that fund into other
line items or other
departments but I don't see
any transf ER of funds to other fund
agencies that I've seen in other um
programs like Medicaid at
Administration and again I just would
like to know where these funds are going
to
um thank you
well I I think we can simply I think the
suggestion of a chart we can we can give
you a sort of a calculation of where
what types of funds are being used and
where they're where they're going that
would probably rather than explaining it
in words and pointing to this line and
that line um I think the picture will
worth a thousand words in this instance
and and and just to clarify
representative priest are you referring
to accounting unit 7948 the 001 transfer
agencies um I'm referring to on page 889
item
um
049 that's the um trans and then on and
then comparing that to the
uncompensated care fund where you
mentioned that the reason why there is
such large
differences of funds from 2024 2025 to
2026 is because those funds are being
transferred to other departments sure so
I I I think I think what we can do is we
can put put together a chart those are
two separate issues though in one case
it's just a TR so in one case um in the
first instance where we have the money
that's going to New Hampshire hospital
that's just showing in the budget we're
going to move that four or so million
dollars in a New Hampshire hospital when
we present on New Hampshire hospital
you're going to see that Revenue coming
into their budget and the corresponding
expenses what we're talking about within
the uh
7948 and uh and the um 79 sorry 7943 and
7948 what we're doing is we're actually
changing the way that we're budgeting
between year between Bania so in one in
the first Bania you're going to see more
of the Met revenue and um in in the
first account and then you're going to
see it in the first year and then you're
going to see a much higher amount in
7948 in the second year because the way
we've crafted the budget is reporting
more of those dollars into the Co
payments and the directed and into the
rates and directed payments and but we
can we can provide a chart to help
explain some of this because it's not
easy to follow given this document
because we're all over the place here so
thank you so so I would add to what
Nathan was saying what is on the line
that you pointed out that those funds
don't come from the Medicaid enhancement
tax
match State facilities get their
uncompensated Care on different basis
and so it doesn't doesn't touch that at
all okay thank you one one important
point for the you know in addition to
the kind of trying to get a better
Federal match where it's available
there's another big um macro issue I
would point out going on here in
2023 Congress um federally passed a law
that um the amount the allocation to
states of uncompensated care called dish
were was going to be
reduced and um we're all following
what's going on now with Congress about
the continuing
resolution absent um addressing this
issue in the continuing resolution New
Hampshire's
allocation for uncompensated care and by
the way New Hampshire has of all the
states in the country has used more of
the dish program than any other state as
a
percentage we would go from over $200
million uh allowance for being able to
draw to under 100 million so we would
see a drop going from 200 and something
million to I think 92 million total so
part of the reason we're migrating out
of the pure uncompensated care is
because the program will be The uncomp
CARE program the dish program is going
to be eventually um by federal law is
going to be shrunk in size and to to be
able to support the level of funding we
have is not just a exercise of trying to
operate within the parameters of what
the law is today but where it's going
and I think the hospitals in the state
are aligned to a to a large degree that
we do need to make this migration
because that aspect you know if it
doesn't happen this year like other
things sometimes Congress continues to
delay but eventually um there's a big
risk in terms of the amount of money
that would be available uh drawing in
traditional
ways okay
um ready for one more um
7948 uh which is on page
right right page
891 Governor's
budget so this is the biggest account
Medicaid this is where we're paying our
our manag care um uh rates which then
you know um just so you know about a
little over 90% of the rate that we pay
to the managed care companies intended
to pay providers so it's it's like n in
the current Managed Care contract it's
about
90.2% on a blended basis of the dollars
that go to them as an insurance premium
if you will capitation rate rate 90% is
is uh the target amount to pay out to to
to Providers and that's that 101 line um
the 535 line and the 563
line um represent um support to uh uh
where Medicaid is allowed um and I call
it braided funding I think that's what
others would call it too where we're
using a combination of um different
types of Federal funding to support um
DCF and other Justice involved children
which which is a practice that's evolved
over time to help um uh capture the
federal dollars that the state is
entitled to um programmatically to
support um cases in and that either need
to be placed you know um out of state or
placed in the community it's it's
combining the 4E funding typically and
the the Medicare paid funding to to uh
you know provide the services and reduce
taxpayers um you see a an increase there
and a and a reduction um I don't know if
you want to speak to that Nathan on the
535 sure the the um the out of home
placements line um you you will see a
reduction there um what what we have
seen in this bium is uh we we are
addressing some of the rule changes at
the federal level relative to Medicaid
funds that we're able to claim um for
certain facilities uh over 16 beds that
provide um certain Services were no
longer able to claim Medicaid dollars so
you will see a reduction there the
department did include a prioritized
needs request to support the general
fund portion based on the projections
that we're seeing for the loss of
Medicaid dollars um and and we're going
to discuss that later at for the
division for Behavioral Health as well
as the division for children youth and
families uh next week when Marine Nunan
comes in we'll be talking about that
prioritized need and this specific issue
um but that program is actually funded
out of three separate accounting units
in Medicaid division for Behavior or
that division for Behavioral Health and
division for children for Youth and
families and it's really depend one of
the challenges there it's really
dependent upon the specific needs and
and what the individual child or youth
qualifies for so as and Henry could was
saying might be Medicaid it might be
tanif it might be for um or it might be
100% General funds it it it's difficult
to predict but um that's that we entered
into contracts for the first time about
three or four years ago and uh this this
change this downward uh reduction here
is to account for some of the changes
that we've seen so representative
Stringham for a question uh just a
clarification on the contracts are we at
risk for services over um running AB
above the um contracted amount uh and if
it goes under are they Li is are the
Managed Care contracts limited to a
certain uh gross profit
margin I guess the answer is yes and yes
but let me explain um so we have um
similar to The Dental contract we have a
minimum medical loss ratio actually in
statute it's uh 85%
I think federally and and and we
actually have a a tighter one than that
we've through the pandemic there was a
lot of expectation of how high costs
would be or not and um so we had on top
of that a risk
hoor today the targeted medical loss
ratio provides for a one and a
half% um margin um the most it can be
above that based on the current contract
um and that can evolve over time as the
risk becomes more stable but as as it's
existed over the past few years and and
in this current year
um the uh the additional profit
potential is up to another two and a
half% so 4% would be the maximum that an
MCO could earn um under this contract um
there's a
7.7% Administration
allowance um both of those are are tight
um to what you would find out there you
know New Hampshire prices um you know
pretty aggressively but solidly in you
know when we've had the uh our
consultants and looking at um you know
for for all the times that we've had
these risk cars the state at least three
out of four times has benefited and has
benefited more um there may be a period
where we don't benefit but we there's a
lot of unknowns and where there are
known um we try to balance that risk um
um between us um and we also follow you
know we we talk to the federal actuaries
because our actuaries do the work then
the federal actuaries do their review
over the their work so it's a highly
scrutinized area um and uh you know I
think that uh it's pretty it's pretty
lean um we have uh we have a price
limitation and and then a budget and
we've in all periods we've been able to
stay within our our budget but not with
a very large margin
forever representative Neno for a
question yeah I just uh Wonder so the um
shift to a different uh model uh I I
wonder what you think the that's an
ongoing process I assume so you're
you're you know incrementally doing that
as you go through the bium so I just
wonder what your sense of what the
additional upside
potential uh exists
for optimization if you
will so I think we we we see for all the
years that we've been doing this and and
every year going forward I think there's
always room to improve what we're doing
um the the areas we're focusing on in
this contract were the big the big
movers we had the the prescription drugs
and and the the gene therapies trying to
deal with that differently but on top of
that on top of trying to do better in
rebates we're also trying to do more
with what we call poly Pharmacy which is
when someone's on a lot of drugs and you
know if you've have family members or
particularly older members that
sometimes different doctors are
prescribing um medications and one
doesn't know what the other is and you
can see someone on you know 30 drugs I'm
not exaggerating in that point but that
what we're what we're trying to do in
this program is to strengthen the
identification of those cases the review
of those cases and using the the New
Hampshire doctors to be more involved in
trying to make therapeutic changes where
there may be um what we describe as
iatrogenic disease caused by the by the
care that you're delivering is to make
sure that we're not doing that so that'
be an area that um you know buying the
drugs at the at a good price is one
thing utilizing the drugs
clinically appropriately is the other
half of it and so we're working both
sides of it and we're leveraging what
the mcos can do and leveraging what our
uh Physicians and providers can do and
that's an area that we have retooled in
this part of the um this most recent
procurement
um so that that you know is is a very
large percentage of our our budget as I
said um you know it's 30 it's going to
probably be by the end of next year
probably a third of what we we spend
then we've also focused on um
preventative Services and strengthening
the the funds that go to local doctors
for doing more um in the care
coordination and preventive Services
because when you look at the L there are
a lot of things that save money but the
a lot of them are kind of ephimeral if
you will and the ones that do seem to
save the money of the preventative
Services and so we're putting more
emphasis on prevention and an authentic
relationship between the patient and the
provider we're we are
um we don't want just a name on a piece
of paper that that's your doc we want
them to be actually being seen and
evaluated um and um we'll be we've also
in the 2.0 procurement and the 3.0
procurement we've had
um uh what we call remedies where there
if there's a lack of performance we can
apply Financial penalties um to make
sure that we're getting the value out of
it and you know that that that seems to
be make the program stronger in terms of
holding the insurance companies you know
um to the standards that they've signed
a contract for so we're continually
working on different areas another area
that um we're working on is
strengthening uh third party liabilities
coordination of benefits subreg uh Co um
coordination benefits I said uh third
party liability strengthening those
where Medicaid shouldn't be the primary
pay like if you think about workers comp
you know sometimes it should be medical
and sometimes it should be workers comp
it's making sure when Medicaid is the
payer it is the correct payer and the
correct order of payer so those are
things that we're doing um and we're
trying to strengthen what the the
department offers there and I could go
on for more time than we want to talk
about all the little areas that we're
you know tweaking all the time but um
you know the only way we're going to
make it work in terms of the budget
that's available to us is to is to
continue to try to move the needle on
number of things lead testing is another
one you know there's been lead testing
in the news we've now working with
public health and with the m cosos and
have Financial penalties and um rewards
for getting to a better level of lead
testing and you know Dr ballad um was
our medical director was on the news
talking about how our rates of testing
have have started to recover after the
pandemic um
so if I may just a quick followup so I
assume you're leaning a lot on it
services to to manage some of these
complex uh uh as you said uh this really
M
multi uh Factor equations and one of the
questions that I think chairman uh
Edwards had asked in a previous session
with the IT people was you know is there
anything that U needs to be done to to
kind
of supplement the services or and then
in turn get a on that investment in the
whole area that you're talking about so
third party liability that I was
speaking to is one of those areas where
we're taking a step in this budget um is
included for us to do what we call data
matching and then to take it further in
a future Capital request um to to be
able to do even more than what what the
that level of uh service would allow us
to do I mean it sounds to me like a an
area where AI would would be a
significant benefit in in pulling all
that together but that's just an opinion
yeah no I mean AI is being used more in
and Technology one of the issues and the
challenges in Medicaid for for vendors
is when you've seen one Medicaid Program
you've seen one Medicaid Program so you
know it's not like taking um software
off the shelf and saying I can use it in
all 50 states and the six territories
it's it's the customization to states
that make some of this more expensive
than you would hope but we do we do have
presentation okay you may proceed okay
um I think um actually the last one is
the is uh Medicaid information system we
see here is on 892
um one of the things I'll say
conceptually about this area is that you
know our Medicaid
um and it's 8009 is the is the U account
number Medicaid management information
system we're actually talking you hear
the term mmis which has been our
historical term and then you'll also
hear the term Medicaid enterprise system
Mees and that reflects um sort of a a
movement to rather than buying one
system to address all your needs is to
be able to have some modularity to be
able to
have more competition in terms of the
the the applications that you have and
um and that's you know the direction
we're trying to move in an intelligent
way um one of the um in terms of this
budget I would say that we when you
think about that um over probably close
to two and a half billion dollars worth
of
claims uh in one way or another flow
through our mismis system when you look
at the general fund costs that are
invested in this while it's a large
number 11 million something it comes out
to less than a half a percent of the
claims paid um and when you look at our
Administration um in the Medicaid
Program the other part of it it's about
a half a percent as well so I mean I
think when you look at the pupil part
and you look at the it part one could
argue that maybe there's underinvestment
there but I think I'm not I'm not
representing that I'm saying you know
we're we're trying to progressively
improve and make make um get advances
there to try to take advantage of other
Technologies probably more where we're
seeing AI is in the eligibility side
which is not part of what's in the the
division of Medicaid services I we have
the the Medicaid information
system um and the way that the federal
match works there is typically on the
capital side um which I know is not part
of it's divided up differently in the
house but the generally acquisition is
approved at a 90% Federal match 10%
State
match um and then there's a um a part a
time period of time in installation
where it's 5050 and then when the system
is certified you get to
7525 part of what's in the Medicaid
budget here is
also um in this particular department is
a is an entity called
NT um which um because CMS is putting so
much money to States they require you to
have like a clerk of the works to make
sure that the investment being made is
sort of uh that the what's expected to
be installed that they're looking to
make sure that their investment is being
protected but
um what we see um um coming in on uh and
we'll have I I think could exhibit later
on here is um the migration to
modularity begins with a system
integrator um functionality that how
you're going to um interface all the
different um uh modules in a way that
they can speak to each other so you know
we've we've been working um to study the
best way to do this looking at other
states what we've found is other states
that have begun with something other
than the system integrator first have
paid to regret that and so we're we're
currently in the process of a
procurement there and that I think
begins our our effort to be able to
create more um opportunities for uh
better um uh pricing potentially than we
otherwise would have and to be able to
bring in new
technology in terms of this this budget
um as I said I think that uh what
uh there's some some extension of our
um event notification system the uh the
uh evv system which is what uh allows us
to see what services are provided that
both has a benefit to us knowing that
patients have received services but also
is also a tool of fraud waste and abuse
to look for that so I think in terms of
um what you're seeing here is some
an increase in costs um reflecting you
know a stepping up on the modularity
space and further deploying some of our
technology that we already have um more
wildly um I'll take any questions you
have
there real real quick one is if you saw
uh reductions in uh number of Medicaid
uh recipients um due to the some of the
things that we're putting in hb2 would
you see a reduction in these numbers
because generally they'd be there'd be
fewer people getting services and about
the same as that were one place you
might see a change in the budget
um there's there's probably some small
components like when we go to um um get
data from an outside Source if we're
doing that less frequently there's
usually um you know a per click kind of
cost in some components but the majority
of the system is sort of like a sunk
cost um you know we have U what we call
a Fiscal Agent um that that interfaces
with 35,000 providers or nearly that
number that are enrolled in the Medicaid
Program you know whether you have 34,000
or
35,000 providers or 185 or 200,000 it's
not much you can do there in terms of
okay proceed Mr lman thank you I was
going to suggest you know maybe five
minute break uh especially for our
speakers too but I know I have a hard
stop at 10 o'clock tonight given the the
rate that we're I'm kidding the but um
okay are you okay with that five minute
break I am keep whatever you want to do
we'll be prepared to do it that sounds
good we'll be back in five minutes thank
you
e
okay division three work session on
February 21st is going to come back to
order uh live on YouTube uh thank you Mr
Lipman Mr White and also joined now at
the table by David David shney uh the
deputy Medicaid director yes U make
yourself at home if you'd like to sit
there or take one of the other seats up
to you and we'll continue where we left
off so I believe that was at
page we go to 19 19 but if we could um
Madam chair um in terms of finishing
covering this before we go further okay
um there are two items is that the
document of five yes okay and we are
going to return back to that too at the
end as a wrap up but yes if you'd like
to refer back to that which number just
in terms of the um in
79 let's see in would be
890 the pages where oh in the governor's
budget the governor's budget the the the
chip is 79 this 7948 is standard
Medicaid Program and 70
79 7051 7051 is the the Children's
Program okay so in terms of the
prescription which is number four the
pharmacy cost sharing um So within the
dollar amounts there is an estimate of
um what we would be collected on
prescription drug copays we do have
copays in place today they've been a
dollar or
$2 for more than a decade and when you
consider um inflation they're probably
like a quarter and 50 cents today in
terms of of uh and so um the allowable
levels for um co-pays are $4 um for uh
for preferred and non-preferred drugs is
up to eight we Cho we chose here I think
to look at um
$4 uh for a couple of reasons one being
that the concept of trying to use the
lowest net cost it could get confusing
over time which is preferred or not
preferred so we'd rather have the
preferred drug list um the other issue
there too is that I mentioned earlier on
the presentation we're trying to
implement these issues if they're passed
in the simplest way without having to
incur major it costs to get them
situated by having one um I think it be
simp simpler to administer and to
program and and
two because of that 5% cap when you're
talking about pre it's not just the
premium it's any co-pays so what we're
suggesting is that where we're charging
a a premium not to have a co-pay on the
medicines so we don't have to add system
complexity and logic to to to track all
these different um dollar amounts so um
the $4 co-pay would apply to people who
weren't paying premiums representative
walner for a question that was my
question would families who were paying
the premium also be paying $4 now no and
so they pay zero they would pay zero
their premium would be their their cost
sharing it's if we were to implement
tracking it separately it would we
wouldn't get it done
very fast and it would be a lot of
dollars to probably get it done because
it' be a major major change right
thank sorry representative tki for
question thank you just to help me
process this so the people who do not
have a premium so the ones who fall
below that the federal poverty
threshold are going to be the ones that
have to pay their
$4 at the pharmacy pay it to the
pharmacy pay it yes today today there's
a dollar or $2 y um instead of a dollar
or $2 it would be $4 except if you were
a a participant that was um paying a
premium
okay so sorry one quick followup as I'm
processing this so
how would you would keep track of those
co-pays on the
pharmaceutical to then get up to the 5%
of income if necessary if they got to
that level yeah it's very un we have to
have a control in place to make sure but
with with the one1 and2 we usually get
nowhere near that and um I think the
$4 it's not di Minimus to the individual
that has to pay it but it's a it's
fairly di Minimus in the scope of what
the the costs are and one last question
you talk often about these extremely
expensive therapeutic
drugs um how does that play into this in
this
situation so a lot of those like the
zenzer example which is the the most
expensive one we've ever experienced um
they come with hospitalization and
so those instances the drugs are part of
typically an inpatient admission or
Hospital outpatient visit so they're not
like what you would go to CVS or WR a or
yep for Walgreens to pick up a script
but even beyond that if you have someone
who's on some kind of more expensive
medication maybe something that's a
couple hundred dollars a a month a
script or whatever um it would be that
$4
correct and the number five um is the
granted Advantage uh program um
typically uh premiums are not allowed
when you're paying under when the
federal poverty limit is um uh below
150%
um as I mentioned
earlier the average tenure on the
program is under a year uh it's like 302
days I think currently is the average
tenure on the
program individuals who leave granted
Advantage often are then their choice of
coverage if they they're making more
than 138% of FPL which is not hard to do
in today's uh economy if you will in New
Hampshire employment space um they um
often would migrate to an ACA product
and there they're going to have co-pays
and deductibles and I think in part
um I think It prepares
individuals um for the fact that that
health care when you're outside of
Medicaid does come with cost um and it
would take a a waiver to get an
exception from the the rule there to to
do this so we have no um no expectation
in 2026 that that would occur um that it
would take us time to work through the
federal process to get that um and again
um there are a lot of details in terms
of what I'm they don't pay or what if
they're in the middle of treatment the
same issues with the children um types
of issues that we'll have to work
through are are are things that we need
to work through there um but I think
that doing a premium is preferential to
cost sharing because then it's at the
provider level where I think you run
into access issues you know if you're
that that um you could argue the other
way but I think in New Hampshire our
experience has been that when you've
tried to do co-pays and emergency for
non-emergency care or other things it
just just adds to the bad debt that the
providers are having and they're less
willing to maybe accept patients who are
on Medicaid so I think um if there is it
going to be a premium and cost sharing
this is I think the the best way to
preserve access from to the providers um
and I know there probably differences of
opinion as to whether a premium should
be there at all but um if there is one I
think this is the the best way to do the
cost
sharing representative Stringham for a
question yeah uh um how many uh total uh
patients are in this block and then how
many how many in the 100 do 135% right
great question do we actually have a
slide on that or okay but we do we
actually when we did the 101 there is
one um there's about 10,000 individuals
who are in that 100 out of the 60,000
that are in the 100 to 138 if I'm
remembering correctly and um the ma the
majority are below 100% um and so they
would be only subject to the $4 co-pays
for prescription drugs thank you if you
give us a moment we can look that up you
just
one yeah actually
11, 167 11,167 when we ran the report
um out of the almost
60,000 so about 16 177% representative
walner for
question so the one thing about granted
Advantage is that this is a program for
very low very lowincome people who in
the past could not
afford Private health insurance and they
probably
used they didn't have their own doctor
they maybe used the emergency room more
or or urgent care centers more that was
where they they were able to get their
care have you seen are you have you seen
some studies that is showing that
they're more likely now to be using
their own physician getting preventive
kinds of services are we saving money
actually because they use it in a better
way I I think that the studies suggest
that um for an individual that to be
access
Care at the appropriate setting is
advantageous to the cost of the system
and to get care right time right place
um and um you know how we would set the
premiums we try to be as sensitive as we
can to not making it go to the wrong
place the most expensive place I think
that we don't want to defeat the defeat
the if you will the the the value that
comes from some cost sharing um to you
know the budget that we're facing um so
I I think we we try to be smart about
you know there times other times that
going way back where New Hampshire for
example maybe you have recollection of
this limited the number of prescriptions
that um someone could get and there's
actually a couple of uh National studies
that New England Journal of Medicine
that showed that wasn't such a good
thing it and it led to more people being
institutionalized so I think you got to
be careful about how you set these
things so they don't have a a boomerang
effect that ends up costing more and
leading to worse health so it's we're
going to have to approach this with
sensitivity just one other question how
how much I mean you must have done some
estimates how much do you think the
state will be receiving from these folks
for their their part of the premium yeah
so it's factored into the budget um it's
uh 12 million in um in the second year
of the
bayum and again we did not assume 100%
collection
yeah thank you and there on an in if at
current poverty levels just to give you
some scaling of it it'd be about
$750 at a 5% level and representative
tarki
question so you didn't assume 100%
compliance what did you assume to get to
that 12 million I'm just
curious um I'm happy to answer the
question but I also I'm a little bit
concerned about putting out the
percentage that people feel that they
wouldn't but I suffice it to say that um
there's a a reasonable percentage of
what we expect to collect I don't want
to put a number out there um because I
don't want to be lower than it otherwise
would be um if that's the policy that's
implemented um but you know we'd expect
that a a number of people are not going
to be able to to pay it's not like 5%
it's it's it's a much higher number than
five
yeah representative Stringham for a
question I mean is your concern as if
the number is 50% you just don't want to
say on Zoom that 6,000 people are going
to lose their health insurance no it's I
think it's just more the collectibility
what the you know I think if we're we're
charging a premium in the program here I
think that in good faith we want people
to pay it if they can pay it and if they
can't pay it then we're going to have
policies to address that I think it's
just don't want to set something up
where we say we don't have an
expectation to pay um and so I think
again you know what representative
walner raised in terms of sensitivities
around people who are in in treatment
that we don't want to do something
that's foolish in terms of saying okay
you're in the middle of chemotherapy
we're not going we're going to cut you
off we knock you off and a month later
you're back on that doesn't make sense
right so I think we we do um need to
carefully um Design This and and
evaluate it in terms of what's the best
way to administer it so that the value
that could be had from it um
understanding some people feel like
and I think some literature you know
shows that it's not a favorable thing to
have cost sharing but I'm I would say
that there are states of both ends of
the spectrum that do have premiums and
have continued to have them um and uh so
I think while it's a policy choice to
still be worked through the legislature
it isn't one that New Hampshire would be
standing alone in and and it has been
something we've done in the past just
quick followup and the um the 5% is that
a ramp or is it a cliff like if you hit
100% you pay 5% of income or is it 1% at
that level and unfortunately it is a it
is a cliff Cliff the the premium though
138 so if I could just if I could just
summarize what you said about you know
the in that 12 million number what the
Assumption was uh that what you're
saying is that you're basing this on
either PR experience and other programs
or looking at other states um uh
experience without disclosing what the
what the number is right I think we do
realize that there is going to be
situations where it can't be paid and we
want to design policies around that as
opposed to just setting an expectation
that it's not paid okay thank
you okay ready to proceed we are
entering Hour 4 so um I don't want to
certainly rush I want you to be able to
say whatever you want to but just uh
keeping track of the time so on on page
19 um and um on the break Uh Kevin
Ripple asked us a question about uh a
figure in
7948 I don't know if you want to address
that
um so the question that Kevin had asked
us uh it it relates to accounting unit
7948 and the uh specifically the
adjusted authorized amount and it's on
page 892 of the governor's operating
budget is where I apologize it's on page
891 there we go um so on
minute yes so on page 891 uh in the
estimated source of funds about 34 of
the way down the page you'll see the
general fund amount the actual expense
in state fiscal year 24 being about $138
million of General funds and then you'll
see that increase there the 226 number
and then you'll see it go back down for
the Governor's recommended
budget so the reason that you do see a
large increase in the adjusted
authorized is based on the existing
state law that that is applicable and it
has been for about 3 or four years years
um the Medicaid Program is able to carry
forward funds within that within the the
101 class line as restricted revenue
from one year to the next and so on page
19 of the PowerPoint presentation that's
before you the the net uh unencumbered
General funds in 7948 is is
approximately almost $29 million once we
take into account the existing
liabilities um and there and the the
item that we did discuss that is in the
hb2 uh document that we were looking at
the other day continues that authority
to carry forward funds from this bium to
the next and part of the reason uh
historical reason for doing that here
and other states do this as well is
because the Medicaid budget is in the
billions of dollars so while the the um
the unencumbered general fund amount is
$28 million if we have a slight change
in the economy or some other change or
the projections differ a year out from
where we started um that 28 million can
get eaten up really quickly because as a
percentage of of a couple billion
dollars it's it's a relatively small
amount I do recognize that it is larger
than some other state agencies in
totality but we're also talking about
the Medicaid budget which is in the
billions of dollars
so and um I think slide 20 we we've um
covered all of these um items in the
discussion but if there's a question on
it we're happy to take it we do have one
if I
may representative tki so what I'm a
little confused by something okay so it
appears that the issues that we
discussed on the five bullet page
document is included for the most part
in the governor adjustments to the
budget yes and not listed
under the part that says hb2 items and
it seems to me that we have a whole lot
of big bucket of policy changes that are
going to come with de specific details
on things and I'm wondering where's that
all going to
land so I think in terms of um during
the break U Kevin Ripple passed out this
piece of paper um I think OS would would
probably um work on these and they might
have some suggestions um but I think
this would represent you know it's it's
basically four paragraphs of of uh each
each of the items except for the granted
Advantage one that um is here I
think so to clarify what you just said
so this paper that got lost on my desk
no um that those this paper passed up
the break yep yep so one two 3 four five
different little paragraphs there you
said this is probably the language it's
going to be used but it's missing the
granite Advantage sorry I stand
corrected that's the third one granted
advantages
five and this will be sorry and so just
to clarify it will be the in an hb2 item
even though the slide says it's not yes
so so so this this is the language that
we anticipate or some there may be some
minor variations that will come out um
in hb2 that OS will release the hb2
document that we were looking at the
other day did include the brand name
versus generic drugs but these are the
remaining five additional policy changes
that have been um incorporated into the
governor's operating budget so the
dollars that you see reflect these
Provisions can I be really simplistic
and ask you to on each paragraph just
tell me what responds to yes the policy
matters on the other so the first one is
the $4 copay which is item four on that
sheet yeah um the the next one is
basically a a an expense reduction in
the administrative area it's saying that
we're only going to do one rate filing a
year um I'm not sure that that is that's
just a I think an expense reduction but
just um then the the next one is um the
granted Advantage one which is number
five
y um the um the the fourth one on that
page is the the children's that going
the
255 and that was number two that would
be number two and number one is the last
one which is restoring the back to the
so the last one we correspond with
number
welcome um if if it's okay um advancing
to uh yes page 21 is basically provided
you've heard a lot and lot thrown at you
this summarizes basically all we went
over in terms of the major changes um
there is that one adjustment that Nathan
made earlier about that that we need to
to correct the The netting out of the
um the expense and the and and
disclosing the revenue um but other than
that that this is faithful to what we
went over as being the major points so
this kind of gives you a a cheat sheet
if you will to looking at all the other
items um and then um moving to page 22
um
these are the support the the
calculations that are um in the
governor's budget um regarding the
return to normal eligibility which is
number one on this sheet and number five
on the other um and and lays out the the
calculations there slide 23 is just a
picture of enrollment um if you go to
the bottom of that page the grand total
um the 17
7420 is where we began the where we had
enrollment as of March of 2020 and the
448 um was as of February 3rd so you can
see at if you go to the top that we're
within 0 4% of on the standard program
um where we were pre pandemic and with
granted Advantage we're 8580 or
16.7% above where we are keep in mind
the policy changes of continuous
enrollment for children um the
postpartum coverage of 12 months
continuous enrollment and I think that
what we've observed which
um will come up in a number I'll point
it out when we get to it um that we see
more people using granted Advantage as
the entry point when they have
disability or or postpartum situation or
um single parent because it's the
easiest one to to be able to get the
health coverage while you're waiting for
other things to play out um slide uh 24
is it gives you a a more a longer trend
line looking at each of the major
eligibility groups um again um be happy
to answer questions offline if you have
any on this um in the interest of time
um just gives you a longer look at it
the the low point which was sort of the
end of all of our unwind activity
largely was November um you can see how
enrollment has changed in each of the
eligibility groups over
time um slide
25 is uh
the gives you a sort of a u a recap of
what's allowable for premium and cost
sharing um and picking up on page uh
26 um is the number two on this sheet
that was handed out earlier and
um number um four on the sheet that
Kevin handed out sorry for that
that um the and then the farmacy cost
sharings on the bottom of that which is
Pharmacy cost sharing is number uh four
on the original sheet that was handed
out and the pharmacy cost sharing is
number one number one on the
hb2 sheet if you will um then the
granted Advantage premiums are on page
27 um and that is uh number three on the
hb2 kind of potential ones and then on
the original sheet that was handed out
um number five and that's you see the 12
million is and just a little bit more
description
there moving to slide 28
um in the AA um 7937 the administration
when I mentioned early on the
presentation the 25% cut um uh that's
just laying that out there and as I
mentioned the ones we highlighted in
green are the ones that have a a great
Roi for the state in terms of the the
spending um in terms of whether it's
drug rebates or making sure the state's
getting what it's supposed to out of its
um you know return on the Managed Care
contracts
um and then um page 29 is the um the
lowest net cost on the drugs which is um
number three on the sheet that was
passed out originally
and that's already in hp2 um this one on
page 29 is the one that is in hp2
already and the reason that the dollar
figure changes from year to year there's
because people are already on drugs and
things like that that it's going to take
some time to migrate to get savings we
actually think the savings will actually
increase in 28 um because it takes some
time to work through um you just don't
want to tell someone you know change a
drug that they're stable on so that's
that's uh why we um and we also
reference the Senate bill that addresses
this
too
um slide 30 it's just the trend in the
Medicaid enhancement tax I think we
um have seen um that uh grow at 348 was
the number that was the preliminary
estimate which um is increase from 319
in in uh the prior year 24 um and you
know we had a we've had mostly the
preliminary estimate has been accurate
except for the pandemic height of the
pandemic um and then on page 31 a little
bit explanation of the met and the
directed payments and the uncompensated
care payments and just an example at the
bottom of how you know um $10 million
can generate different levels based uh
based on a straight match of 50/50
match um page
uh
32 um is basically the the the current
um way that uh the sort of the Met is
deployed in
the in the budget if you will um so
there's you got the 25 year which is the
current year that we're in under the 80%
plan um then you get what 26 is based on
estimates that were originally produced
as we can see already in 25 that um the
the 26 years has already been
outperformed and um we're at
348 and and the non-binding estimate so
hopefully this helps a little bit with
the reconciliation of where the dollars
are
moving um page 33 is an explanation of
state phase down um that you can walk
away
with and then the number I quoted
earlier 273 is currently what we're
paying
um page
34 is um request that I think came from
the
chair to look at what has been added to
the Medicaid Program in terms of
services and
eligibility we do have a handout that we
can leave with you we there's a bit of
work that has to be done to compile that
I think we've got all the changes we
haven't got all the dollar put together
yet but we can leave that with you and
answer any questions on that that would
be great and then it can be posted to
our website of information perfect y if
we could just put it will be updated and
we'd like to replace it when it's fully
um but at least you can see all the
changes sure and we also provide the
statutory reference whether it's state
or Fe or
federal excellent thank you um page 35
is the medic K schools program and sort
of reviewing what it is um the issue of
transitioning to a
different um claiming methodology and
what a um while we talk about schools
it's
really Medicaid's built on local
Education Agency which can in a town
that has multiple schools can be
multiple schools can be like Manchester
example versus another town may only
have one school or two schools so
they're all different sizes but the unit
that gets paid the dollars is an Lea
um and then lastly um um uh following
that is on page
36 is what uh the participation has
been and how it's changed over the
years um the the number ones that are to
the right of some of the dollar figures
there are the fact that there was also
the Federal match the enhanced Federal
match that was available at one point it
was instead of 50% it was 56.2% that
that was passed on directly to the
school so these numbers don't include
that additional amount but you can see
the program has shrunk um over over time
and I think there's a real opportunity
to um changing this methodology and
hopefully with the the grant to um
provide more resources to schools and I
think also we need to look at how
special ed and and Medicaid schools
connect in terms of dollars that are
available federally versus um and but I
know that isn't a a two-e
exercise turning to um representative
tarki for a question thank you before we
if the next slide is the potential
Federal implications which I think could
probably give us another four hours on a
different day but before we go there um
page 893
of the governor's budget which I think
is the bottom line for Medicaid the 1.3
billion the
1.3 billion yes um when I look at the
2025 adjusted
authorized then go over to the 2026
recommended I figured it's a difference
m696 64
and I don't expect an answer to this
question but I'm wondering if there
could be some kind of graphic or chart
that can be produced that tells
us what is that what is going away with
that $71
million what's how did we get there in
very sort of simple words if I'm going
to have to explain it to my
constituents so I I I think the first
thing that's important to think about
when looking at that is is you're not
comparing the same numbers so you're
comparing the adjusted authorized amount
and not necessarily the budget amount
and so the adjusted authorized amount
includes that $94 million of carry
forward that we were referring to
earlier but one thing that we could do
is we could look at what was
appropriated by hb1 and the current bium
we can add in the hb2 we can try to add
in the hp2 and maybe the state fiscal
year 24 legislation impacting that as
well and then kind of crosswalk that and
then there's a table I think it was back
on page 21 that we could try to
incorporate in there as well so you can
you can kind of see what are the
differences I think another really
important um feature here is when we
build our budget it's we we work with
the actuaries to really look in look
into the details to try to project as
accurately as possible what the needs
are what the capitation rate is going to
be and what the total expenses uh will
be as well so we can work on trying to
crosswalk this and and get something
that makes a little bit more sense
because I don't think adjusted authorize
is always the best sort of compar
comparative point I thank you for that
and I understand this is so super
complicated which is why I'm trying to
figure out how to actually be able to
communicate it to someone who hasn't
been sitting in this committee room um
because I think what I'm hearing is
people are really concerned and they're
really concerned about what this budget
potentially could mean um for their
day-to-day lives and caring for their
families we want to be supportive of
making it clear as we can and so we will
we will provide thank you support you in
that
regard
um so on
page 38 um we've identified some of
the representative priest for a question
thank you uh going along with um my
fellow representative representative
triski
given the time and given
the important
nature of federal
initiatives and potential budget in cuts
and what's happening now in Washington I
think we should dedicate a time just to
talk this
through because things could change
week okay uh my thought there is that we
have bookings essentially for work
sessions until March 11th is that right
Mr Ripple is March 11th the last
scheduled day it's the last scheduled
work session I believe we're going to
add the uh prescription drug
affordability board to the 12th so there
will be one more after
that okay um let's see what we can do
about adding we have nothing next Friday
and I think if we have and we could
posted in the next journal
what um I mean that's just an an idea to
throw out yes understood uh my thought
is uh perhaps we add it to the final the
prescription topic on what day is that
Mr Ripple that'll be on March 12th
possibly on March 12th possibly so let's
uh keep that in
mind okay yeah given the uh
intensity of the subject matter today
it's it's really amazing that you
can continue for Four Stall it hours
you've done a fantastic job you and your
team uh and but again it just
demonstrates just how detailed and um
extensive this topic is okay so um
without uh keeping in mind what was just
discussed I think uh um on page um 38 I
think those are all things if any of any
one of those come into place um there's
Major Impact on on budget and and
coverages and so forth um the work
requirement um is um a piece of
legislation that uh the reason I bring
it up here is if there's an active um
bill in the Senate that has passed
committee um it um directs the
department to implement what was
previously um
um vacated by the court and um ended by
um but I think part of the things that
might happen as part U at the state
level but also at the federal level
there could be a change in policy there
um and what I wanted to point out
because it's a financial item is that um
because it was the all the work that we
did it wise um we we maintained it but
if we were required to implement it
exactly as it is today and it is in
statute today
already um there because it was ended
and vacated we did not keep it in sync
with everything else there would be a
cost which we identify as about 1.7
million in total funds to be able to get
it back in sync with the
system beyond that I think there's also
a need to look at what Congress says
about it they may create an easier path
they may create uh the new
Administration May create different
standards than the previous
administration so um what I'm trying to
alert you to is just passing and saying
us to do it again is not a free item
that there there is going to be a cost
associated with that um
whether um what that would be is I'm
just alerting to you to that it's not
just resubmit and there's the and just
start it up again they their it costs
and then they also possibly possibly
Staffing costs to administer it um so
just to um add to what you're saying
that Senate Bill 134 yes currently I see
the docket right now and it looks as
though it's in the Senate yes it has
reported out of committee ought to pass
with Amendment so I would encourage
everyone to look at the amendment number
0401 lower case s which essentially
replaces the bill it came out of uh the
senate committee 3-2 and it looks like
it's to be determined on the house on
the senate floor yes the the amendment
effectively they had us having to submit
it by July 1 which is pretty unrealistic
if the legislative session goes to you
know June and a budget year um and they
changed the date to January 1st of uh 20
um six would be the date that we'd have
to submit it so that was the major
change that I think is the
amendment and okay um just identifying
just on the side here I'm sure it's a
bill that probably would need to an FN
ultimately um and then slide um just
representative elano for question just a
very quick question and because I
haven't paid attention to this over the
years I've lived here but didn't we have
a work requirement at one other point in
our history so in
2018 um s SP
313 um required us to apply for a waiver
for work requirement we applied for it
received it and started to implement it
and then um the court um here in New
Hampshire and if you look at the next
page um there's a map in the United
States uh colorcoded of which states had
an approval and um and which states were
denied um and then on the right hand
side is a recap on Georgia currently
um based on I think the district court
in that area were able to implement
something they're making some changes
Arkansas which New Hampshire and
Arkansas were approved around the same
month I believe um Arkansas is is going
back as well
um we could certainly spend more time on
this topic if uh if in fact it has
um approval here and if there's Federal
41 and um is basically some statistics
uh produced by the Kaiser Foundation um
over a couple of year time frame that
gives you some sense of what who's
working that's in the Medicaid Program
our work at the height of the pandemic
when granted Advantage was like 97,000
uh uh uh enrollment the number of people
working was at 70% today it's uh it's
less than that it's around the US
average a little bit better um but this
gives you some sense of in the you know
from a a secondary source of what what
it looks like in New Hampshire today um
the next two slides um on page
42 and 43 42 is an example of looking at
the
the two populations by who was enrolled
in a given month these these numbers a
little bit higher than you've seen
earlier because we're looking at anybody
who is enrolled during the month um but
that's just sort of the trend there um
from for going all the way back to 2014
to to fiscal year 25 just to give you a
sense of what's been happening in the
program
um globally then on page 43 was a point
I was trying to make earlier is that um
you can see that people with adults with
disabilities parent parenting adults and
Pregnant postpartum women that there are
uh fewer because we believe that they're
taking advantage of the the opportunity
to get health care sooner by going
directly to granted Advantage if that
were to the the issue here right for the
state from a financial standpoint when
they're in granted Advantage it's a 90%
Federal match when they go back to a
standard program we Dro to a 50% match
and so you know there's a factor to
consider in terms of what the net cost
of ending um expansion would be in terms
of um on the state directly as well as
the insurance
markets and
um moving to page 45 uh this is sort of
the appendix but we had one prioritized
need that got approved which is uh
project walk program which is a
individuals who um have issues with
Mobility where generally the medical
rehab um wouldn't provide any further
supports to help them um be able to be
more mobile that this takes them a
little bit further um it's uh something
that uh was started in
um I guess the end of 20 24 in um it's
continued in in this uh in the
um um in page um 46 and
47 46 is a a slide we've used to sort of
um lay out all the things that we did in
on one page to help with uh you know
keeping keeping people covered who could
who were eligible and and supporting
those who weren't um but the the overall
statistics of the unwind are what you
find on page 47 um and the grand total
of the sort of the flesh tone colored
line is
um people who um retain coverage was
just under
70% um in total but what we saw is that
the people who were what we call the
protected group those were people who
protected in the sense that they had
continuous coverage through that 4-year
period
um up to the 4-year period that they
renewed at a much lower level than um
the individuals who um were under the
under had come on more recently and you
know we're seeing there that they
renewed at a rate of almost 84% if we
were looking at some more current
statistics we'd actually see with the
expart renewal flexibilities that we're
seeing a renewal rate approaching n over
9 % but once once the the authorities
for the flexibility go away we're
expecting that to drop by about
20% um and that's where some of those
calculations of fewer people renewing
come
from um page uh 48 is um just a summary
of the you know sometimes people talk
about um which uh programs that you
should should offer or not and we
highlighted the mandatory services and
the the yellow items on the bottom of
that chart there were the ones that are
considered under the ACA essential
health benefits and and you know things
that we have covered in the Medicaid
Program is you know you wouldn't think I
think today to not cover prescription
drugs and for children not to give them
eyeglasses and who need it and um you
know even uh mental health is considered
an optional service um but it I think
just provided this because this
sometimes comes up when people talk
about Medicaid um then page 49 gives you
some um comparisons of New Hampshire's
eligibility um criteria versus the
nation I think as we emphasized earlier
that with respect to Children New
Hampshire has you know the fifth highest
eligibility in the country when it comes
on uh slide 50 is the the federal match
which we we brought that slide up
earlier um 51 is just an explanation of
how Federal match
Works um and page 52 is a just a table
of the different match rates and on the
$1,000 53 is uh guess with time I'm
going to just this is the community
re-entry program it's the 1115 waiver
program it sort of summarizes that and
on the bottom it summarizes the youth
re-entry program kind of the key
features of those programs again I think
if you're really interested in this it
deserves you know much longer time than
than that but it just gives you at least
a basic on that and again what you're
taking us through is the appendix so
you've provided all this as supplemental
to your
presentation um and then on 54 and 5 uh
4 is so some highlights of the
reprocurement of what we did in 3.0 to
make the program better um and then 55
gets into the things I talked about
earlier on medication the two major
initiatives there in terms of within the
the more recent
procurement
um
56 um shows the distribution of the
capitation rate where the money is spent
you'll notice in the the sort of the
lighter brown area that um the outside
says 25.2% the inside says 31% the
difference is the 31% is just of the
medical spend not the administration or
or profit component or the premium tax
um when you look at the medical spend
it's 31% of that um 50 page 57 are
Trends on utilization um in both the the
granted Advantage program and standard
program that we've been following over
time their utilization rates per
thousand um I know that was an interest
of at least one member of the committee
to have some insights into that we can
provide more but this is sort of a high
level you know look that we do follow it
and are some links to take you to
different um places to look at more
detail detail um on page uh 68 is
um um the uh
you know New Hampshire um this is
something CMS tracks in terms of the
number of measures that New Hampshire
participates in we're one of the higher
ones um and then on page uh
69 is a summary of the the federal
scorecard of of where we're not doing as
well as we'd like to that we actually
have metrics that we're already working
on to get better in and then of the
areas we're doing excellently we have
nine out of 10 we have metrics that
we're tracking we could do a lot more on
quality if you're interested in that
almost made
4:30 okay thank you very much I see that
in your formal presentation with the
appendix
included so at this point I'll ask for
any wrapup questions related to your
presentation I would like to also see if
anyone has any further remarks on this
document of five that was passed out
earlier and on the website
any comments on preliminary House Bill
two and then anybody from the public if
they would like to comment so let's
start with any wrapup questions to the
overall presentation at this point
representative Daniels for a question
thank you on the
255 uh% threshold yes uh who sets that
and how long has it been in place so the
255 is the national median um that's out
there in terms of if you look at all
states where they set their FPL federal
poverty limit we're at
323 you know there's some states below
255 that's just the national median so
we thought that in terms of a picking a
point of which to start a premium you
know it's higher than it was we work to
cut it we work to cut it down that's it
I think we all believe that's the
condensed version be true the fivepoint
document any further thoughts comments
questions related to anybody around this
table representative tarki thank you
this has been CH full and I feel like
we're just scratching the surface um you
alluded to this but I see a lot of um
Representatives out there who they
represent providers and I think we
haven't even touched the conversation on
what this is actually going to mean for
providers our hospitals um substance use
disorder uh treatment um and how this is
really going to affect patients in the
exam room and in the doctor's office so
at 20 minutes of 5 I'm a little
concerned by just saying does anyone
have a comment and I'm wondering if we
would be able to schedule a time to
actually give some dedicated
conversation to the
providers let me consult with the
division chair but I'm sure that can be
arranged thank you
representative
Stringham I know there there's some
areas in there that I've inquired about
but uh in particular I'm I'm concerned
whether there's any areas uh in uh in
Medicaid rates where we're
seeing um uh access issues uh uh and and
might be appropriate for targeted rate
increases my understanding is there's no
change in rates um uh built in
uh to this budget despite uh you know 3
to 4% inflation rates over uh each of
the last two years so if you want to
comment on that I'd appreciate
it it's it's correct that this budget
does not have rate increases in Medicaid
rate Medicaid budget um this portion of
the Medicaid budget I'm not sure what
the other divisions if they have
anything um
um but um the uh Senate bill um I think
it was
243 had um I think $20 million per year
but I think that was um the action at
the end of last week that they cut that
down um um so I think that that that's
the only Bill then there's there may be
some other bills out there that I'm not
aware of that that are separate from hb1
if you will um that have rates it's I
mean I think the
the targets um didn't allow for that um
can you comment at all the on the
maternity Services uh and and how how um
uh that provider network has responded
to the rate increases from the last few
years well um in terms of as you know
for hospitals um we provided a a 24%
increase for the larger hospitals and a
34% increase for the delivery of babies
we um
hb2 had um the increases the across the
board increases that were given to
providers for the providers and then for
the birthing centers there were um there
were two there was before HB uh 2 there
was an increase and there was another
increase a part of hb2 in 2023 there's
also in that bill I was referencing um
there's a
$30,000 study as to what can be done
more to support birthing centers um and
that Senate bill that I was referring
to so so are they prosperous and and
thriving or are they uh flailing and
failing so I think one of the um I to be
frank I don't know directly but one of
the major issues I do know that was
driving them to ask for higher rates was
the malpractice insurance Market had
sort of seized for them um and part of
address okay anything further the
document of
five okay the preliminary House Bill two
I call it preliminary because as we know
as was raised earlier there's nothing in
there any comment remark or question
about
anything in there now
okay at this point I want to open it up
to anyone in the audience who would like
to make a comment and thank you
gentlemen so very much thank you for
your attention felt that long a time I
audience
okay all right if you could just make
sure your microphone is on and your name
is very clear and who you represent sure
I'll be very very quick too my name is
Kate fry I am the vice president of
advocacy and new Futures I really just
want to underscore the comments made
earlier that if we just could have more
information with a a crosswalk and maybe
another point in time that people can
providers and those who may be impacted
by these changes could um bring that
information forward that'd be great
because this is all new information and
it's 4:30 and 4:45 and we're all very
tired but I do want to thank the the
committee and the department for the
presentation thank you very much for
your comment questions from anyone all
right yes step right up and again be
sure your microphone is on and your name
is very clear good afternoon Don mckenny
New Hampshire Legal Assistant I agree
with what was just said about a public
opportunity for comment one specific
suggestion and I apologize if I missed
this already because I was in and out a
lot trying to go cover a couple things
um but I was hoping to get more
information about the cost to implement
some of the changes that are being
suggested in terms of particularly
premiums and co-pays um I didn't hear
those implementation costs I I saw on
page um 39 about the implementation cost
for the work requirements for example I
would think that there would be similar
costs for those other changes as well
and and I just didn't hear that so I
wanted to note that for maybe if thank
you you're referring to uh page 39 of
the presentation today right okay that
that specifically outlines the cost to
for work requirements but I didn't see
something similar around premiums and
co-pays those have got to be
significantly expensive to implement
administratively and um just think that
that should be factored into the based
on the proposals that the working
document that was circulated and posted
online today very good thank you okay
thank you any questions thoughts all
right anything further from anyone in
the
audience
okay at this point I would like to
remind committee members that division 3
will meet on Wednesday February
26th at 1 pm in this room it is duly
publicized in the most recent calendar
it is a budget
yes don't we meet
before uh no okay uh our next meeting
26th
so our next meeting Wednesday February
26th 1 pm in this room it is a budget
work session for the division of
children youth and
Families we then meet after that on
Thursday February 27th at 10:00 a.m. in
this room budget work session for the
division of Behavioral Health and all of
those are in the calendar for next week
so that is seeing us through next week
we're going to close with any comments
all right at this point then we are
going to close the work session of
division 3 thank you all very much and
we will see you at our next work session
Wednesday